WILL COME TO ORDER- GOOD
AFTERNOON- IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY. IN
ORDER TO THE PUBLIC SENATOR.
THANKS STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GOD AND TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING AN ESSENTIAL HEARING
AND IS VERY NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE. THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE TO
LEGISLATIVE FROM US WHAT
CONDUCTING THE- AID OF TAX HELL
SAFETY OF THE POP. ARMED. AT
ARMS FIRST. FIVE ORDERS WE ARE
HOLDING OUR CAN. IN A CAPITAL
WITH SOME OF OUR KEY MEMBER TO
IN THE BAY REMOTE WITH THE USE
OF A VIDEO. SIX SENATOR WILL BE
PROCESS. REMOTELY BERMAN WHO
WILL BE A TWO THE TODAY PLEASE.
YOU YOUR OR CA TO BUY IT IN THE
AND YOUR SIX BACK BYPASS THAT
ARE AND YOU HAVE A MENTOR
SESSION USED RAISE YOUR HAND
THE PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOUR
KNOWLEDGE SPEAK UP POP UP WHEN.
SAYS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TWO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
I WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE BUT FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TEST I TODAY NOT FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PRINT I
PUBLIC COMMON. SEVEN FREE
NUMBER. ACCESS IT IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. THEY
WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AND I WILL ANNOUNCE IT HERE AND
I'M GONNA IN ORDER TO PROTECT.
THE PUBLIC. WHO WERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WE'RE ASKING YOU
TO TESTIFY USING THE TELEPHONE
SYSTEM AS WELL. IT'S PRETTY.
NUMBER IS ONE. EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE. SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
SIX OF SEVEN. ONE OH THREE TWO
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
TO A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY
YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LINE
AND AT THAT TIME YOU MAY
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT ORDER TO HEAR YOU
LEARLY AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST TO MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE USING TO WATCH
THE HEARING- PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE- IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND IF THE- IS ALSO
BROADCASTING ON YOUR COMPUTER
IN THE BACKGROUND THAT WILL BE
DIFFICULT WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM. AS THE MARRIED AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE HAVE THE
CONNECTIONS MUTED. LAW EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS.
THANK YOU DOCTOR HEARINGS AND
AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR SENATE STAFFER DOING
AN EXTRAORDINARY JOB. UNDER
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES SETTING
UP THIS NEW UNPRECEDENTED
SYSTEM. THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES WHICH IS A CONSUMER
ADJUSTING TO. THE USE OF NEW
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENCE SO ALL INTERESTS
AGAINST THE PROPERTIES CAN BE
HEARD. SO WE WILL NOW COME WE
HAVE EIGHT BILLS. ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. BUT BEFORE WE HEAR
PRESENTATION ON THESE BILLS
WHICH WILL BE ON FILE ORDER WE
WILL ESTABLISH A QUORUM- AND SO
WILL SECRETARY PLEASE. CALL THE
ROLL TO ESTABLISH CORN. MEMBERS
PLEASE REMEMBER TO HAVE THE
START TO TURN ON YOUR MIKE
BEFORE YOU ANSWER SENATOR
WINNER. PRESIDENT WIENER
PRESENT MORALE HERE MORRELL
HERE CABALLERO PRESENT AVEIRO
PRESENT TORONTO HERE TORONTO
HEARING ON MCGUIRE. MORAL
RESIDENTS MORE LIKE PRESENT
ROUGH HERE ROUGH HERE SKINNER.
NUMBER WE CASKEY HERE WE CAN
SEE HERE. SEVEN OKAY WITH SEVEN
MEMBERS CURRENTLY PRESENCE
WHICH ESTABLISHES A QUORUM WE
EXPECT THE OTHERS SHORTLY- AND
AGAIN AS A REMINDER SENATOR
BATES IS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY- TODAY- I WOULD LIKE
US OF CENTER THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. OKAY AS I MENTIONED
WE'RE GOING TO BE GOING AND
FILE ORDER. SO WE WILL NOW HEAR
FROM OUR FIRST AUTHOR- FILE
ITEM ONE SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE-
BY SENATOR BELL. AND SENATOR-
YOU MAY PRESENT THAT'S THE
SEVEN SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMA AND
MEMBERS- I'M PRESENTING SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE- A BILL THAT
CREATES A SUSTAINABLE STATE
FUNDS SOURCE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WELL GENERATED HIGH
WAGE JOBS. THE BILL INVEST TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
FIVE YEARS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS AND
PROGRAMS AND THE AT THAT PRESS
IN PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
ADDITIONAL THE BILL. TWO NEW
PROGRAMS IN MINISTERED BY THE
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT GO BILLS TO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH THEIR
ECONOMIC RECOVERY. AND NATURAL
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS. OF THE
TWO BILLION DOLLARS OVER TWO
THIRDS OF THE FUN SO SHALL BE
USED TO CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. SPUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. AND CREATE JOBS
THROUGHOUT THROUGHOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE EMPLOYMENT
PROGRAMS THE REMAINING ONE
THIRD WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE HOMELESS HOUSING ASSISTANCE
AND PREVENTION PROGRAM- OF TO
SUPPORT REGIONAL AND LOCAL
HOMELESSNESS EFFORTS. NOW
FOCUSING ON HOUSING PRODUCTION
ASSIST IN CAL CALIFORNIA IS
COVERED NINETEEN RECOVERY IN
TWO WAYS. FIRST BY CREATING
MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
PROACTIVELY PREVENT MORE
FAMILIES FROM BECOMING HOMELESS
SECONDLY WE GENERATE HIGH WAGE
JOBS IN HOUSING PRODUCTION. NOW
I CAN BEND A GOVERNOR FOR
INVESTING TO SERVE THE
IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF THOSE FAKE
FACING HOMELESSNESS BUT THESE
INVESTMENTS FAILED TO ADDRESS
THE ROOT CAUSE OF OUR
HOMELESSNESS PROBLEM. WHICH IS
THE LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS. LEADING TO THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT HOUSING PRODUCTION
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
ALMOST ENTIRELY FUNDED WITH
BOND REVENUE. AND THERE'S A
LIMITED FUNDS REMAINING.
FURTHERMORE ALL FOUR WERE
HOUSING PROGRAMS ARE
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER SUBSCRIBED.
IN TERMS OF APPLICANTS
REQUESTING THE FUNDS SOME AS
HIGH AS 4100% FOR EXAMPLE MULTI
FAMILY RENTAL PROGRAM RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS TOTALING OVER ONE
BILLION DOLLARS A FUNDING
REQUEST BUT ONLY AWARDED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN FINES.
STALLING MANY PROJECTS READY
FOR CONSTRUCTION. IF WE DO NOT
INVEST IN HOUSING PRODUCTION
FRAUD PROJECTS NOW. WE WILL RUN
OUT OF MONEY SOON AND THEN
DRAMATICALLY SO DOWN HOUSING
PRODUCTION. AT THIS TIME I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO MY WITNESSES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR-
BELL AND- YOUR LEAD WITNESS IS-
JASON RHYNE- FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA. CITIES AND BEFORE I
JUST WANT TO- STATED DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF HEARINGS. TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATIONS A NEW CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEES- INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY
ACCORDINGLY EACH SIDE WILL ONLY
BE PERMITTED A TOTAL OF THREE
MINUTES. WHICH CAN BE ONE
WITNESS ARE DIVIDED. ALL OTHERS
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON IT
THE IS SO AGAIN JASON ROB AND
FROM THE LOOK ON HIS. IS THE- I
IDENTIFIED WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. ON MISTER RYAN
YOU MAY PROCEED. CATION RIGHTLY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER.
RIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBER STATION RYAN LEE
CALIFORNIA CITIES- GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY THIS MORNING
AND IS CERTAINLY UNIQUE TIMES
THEY WERE ALL WORKING UNDER-
WE'RE HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE BY SENATOR
BILL FROM THE CENTER HAS BEEN A
TREMENDOUS ADVOCATE FOR HOUSING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND A TRUE
CHAMPION WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE ALL HIS LEADERSHIP
ALONG SIMILAR YOU KNOW SITTING
AROUND THE DICE OF THIS
COMMITTEE- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
MISTER BELL THIS COMMITMENT. ON
THIS MEASURE WE VIEW IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- THIS BILL
IS AS THE SENATOR MENTIONED
WOULD PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT LONG
TERM RESOURCES TO TRY NEW TRUE
HOMELESS AND OF HOUSING
PROGRAMS WE KNOW THE PROGRAMS-
KNOWING INITIAL RESOURCES IN
THE GROUND IF WE'RE GOING TO
SEE ANY HOPE CONSTRUCTION WE
ARE BRINGING ABOUT THE TWO NEW
PRO IS OVER I MEAN GOMEZ- RC
DIVIDED AND BILLION DOLLAR
SHORTFALL IN REVENUE LOSSES
OVER THE NEXT TWO BUDGET CYCLE-
YOU'RE GONNA NEED SIGNIFICANT
ECONOMICAL THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
WE REALLY DO THOSE PROGRAMS. TO
GET DOWN I'M SORRY SIR SUPPORT
THAT WE ARE ALSO YOU DON'T
COGNIZANT OF THE SENATE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AFTER AROUND THE
BUDGET THIS YEAR ON THE STATE
IS FACING UNIT BUDGET DEFICIT
HOW MUCH LIKE PERSON SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S THESE ARE
DIFFICULT TIMES AND DOLLARS ARE
SHORT- BUT WE THINK THAT TO
HOUSING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
CREATING GOOD JOBS I'M MORE
LEAD. INTO THAT EVERY. SOME OF
THOSE OF PROGRAM IF THERE'S
TIME. WE NEED TO SURE THERE THE
BILL PROBLEM LEAVE IN THE OVER
THE LAST YEAR WE HAVE NO CHANGE
I'M TO HOW ARE CITIES ZONE A
PLAN AND YOU KNOW HOUSING. THAT
SOME OF THE DOLLAR INTO MY AND
I IF WE'RE GOING YOU KNOW MOVE
FORWARD THE DISH CHANGE A
RECORD OF THE HOW DO PACKAGE AS
COLLECTED WE CERTAINLY HAVE TO
HAVE A CAR. AROUND AND WE
REALLY DO THIS IS THE START
THAT COMMERCE ABOUT THAT
INSURANCE URGE YOUR VOTE ON
THIS SEVEN FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH MISTER
RYAN. WE WILL NOW CONTINUE WITH
ANY. WHO WORKS IN GALLERY.
ABOVE NO. NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE PRESENT TODAY AND-
IN THIS ROOM- WILL NOW PROCEED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY LET'S
CHECK IF THERE ANY WITNESSES-
ROUTE TWENTY FORTY SEEMS QUITE
EMPTY- SO THERE COULD BE NO
WITNESSES AROUND TWENTY FORTY.
WE WILL NOW MOVES- TO ANY
WITNESSES TESTIFYING. IN
SUPPORT- BY TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE AGAIN FOR THOSE
WITNESSES PLEASE SIMPLY STATE
YOUR NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IF
ANY- AND YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL AND THIS IS FOR SUPPORT.
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
INDIVIDUALS. THE MODERATOR- HE
YEAR INSURED RIGHT FROM LA
COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION
WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO THE
PUBLIC RIGHT NOW FOR SUPPORT
YES THIS IS FOR SUPPORT VIA
TELECONFERENCE FOR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC. IF YOU ARE IN THE
POOREST PRESSED ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO LINE
SIXTY THAT SIX ZERO. THEY JUST
REMOVE THEMSELVES LET'S GO TO
LINE SIXTY THREE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR CENTER ABOUT NOT
ROBINSON ON THE TOP OF THE
CEMETERY CALTRAIN THE DISTRICT-
WE SUPPORT THE REVISED VERSION
OF SEVEN NINETY FIVE-
PARTICULARLY ACCESS TO TRANSIT
AND THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROVISIONS THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL THAT ONLINE SIXTY FOUR. MR
KERRY MEMBERS STILL BE AT THE
LEASE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA IN SUPPORT. MEXICO
BUT ONLINE FIFTY SIX. IF THE
FAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING
AND SUPPORT. NEXT WE WILL
THAT'LL NINE FORTY NINE. ATTY
TUNING WITH THE BAY AREA
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. NEXT WE
WILL THAT ALIGN FIFTY FIVE.
LOOK NO ONE ON THE AFTER THE
SILICON VALLEY COMMUNITY
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND NEXT WILL THAT ONLINE
FIFTY TWO. JERRY FROM TECH
EQUITY IN SUPPORT. AND THEN
NEXT WE WILL BUT A LINE FORTY
FOUR ZERO. HI ALLEY CANNINGTON
WITH THICK HEALTHY AND WE
SUPPORT THE SEVEN FIVE THANK
YOU. NEXT BILLS ONLINE FORTY
THREE. HI THIS IS INSTRUCTOR
WITH THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN NINE FIVE.
WE WILL THAT ONLINE SIXTY. YOUR
ENTRY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
BEVERLY HILLS WE SUPPORT THAT
WE SEVEN NINE FIVE. NEXTEL BUT
A LINE TWENTY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS AFTER AND GOT A
DEAL WITH BURBANK HUSING WE
ARE IN SUPPORT SB SEVEN NINE
FIVE. AND THERE IS NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU CAN YOU TEST- CHECK ONE
MORE TIME TO. DETERMINE IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE WAITING TO
SPEAK BY TELECONFERENCE.
QUESTION IF ANYONE OUT OF THEM
FOR PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CALLING FOR MANY ON BEHALF THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT OF MANDATE WE DO
HAVE BEEN CONCERNED THAT. THE
CURRENT VERSION OF A BILL
CREDIT INCREASE CASA
CONSTRUCTION UNNECESSARILY. WE
ARE YOUR SUPPORT TO KEEP THE
BILL THAT I. ARE THERE ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES ON
TELECONFERENCE IF THE MODERATOR
COULD PLEASE DETERMINAR.
THERE'S ONE RIGHT NOW AND I
WILL NOW FOR THEM IN JUST A
MOMENT. ANY THE NO ONE IS
REMAINING THIRTY THREE. I HAD
LINE THIRTY THREE. HELLO THIS
IS JILL SHOOK WITH MAKING
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY HAPPEN
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN AT NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
NO ONE OUT THANK YOU OKAY KATIE
ONE FINAL CALL. IF YOU ARE
READING. YEAH IN THE AREA.
HOLLY FOR MANY OF YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A CHAPTER NINETY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AS AMENDED IF YOU HAVE
CONCERNS THAT THE CURRENT
BURGEONING BUILD COULD INCREASE
CONSTRUCTION COSTS
UNNECESSARILY. AND WE LIKE THAT
BUT WE COLLECTED A BILL KEEP
MOVING AND WE CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON THE
PROVISIONS THANK THANK YOU
NUMBER- ASKING FOR THE
TELECONFERENCE FOR SINCE IT'S
THE CITY NAME AFFILIATION AND-
POSITION. OUR ANY ADDITIONAL.
PEOPLE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE TO THE MODERATOR. I HAVE A
NINE FORTY. HI MY NAME IS ALLEY
CANNING AND I'M WITH THE
HEALTHY AND WE SUPPORT AT THE-
I THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE
MODERATOR THERE ANYADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WAITING
ONLINE OR ON THE TELECONFERENCE.
YES ONE MORE AND ALL NOW LET ME
JUST A MOMENT. LINE SEVENTY ONE.
GREAT RECOVERY SIEVERS ON
BEHALF OF ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICAN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THERE'S NO ONE OUT TO MAKE
YOUR- OKAY ONE FINAL CALL THE
MODERATOR OR THE NEW PLEASE DO
A FINAL CALL FOR ANYONE WHO'S
WAITED TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
THAT THERE IS ANYONE OUT OF THE
PARK PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND THERE'S NO ONE IN Q. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW
MOVE TO OPPOSITION PRESS THE
SEVEN NINETY FIVE WERE UNAWARE
OF ANY LEAD WITNESSES SO WE'LL
START OUT WITH- THE GALLERY
HERE IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS IS
OR ANYONE PRESENT IN THE
GALLERY TO TESTIFY AGAINST SB
SEVEN NINETY FIVE. AC NINE WILL
MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
WHICH CONTINUES TO LOOK QUITE
ANTI SO NOW MOVES TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THE
MODERATOR- DO WE HAVE PEOPLE ON
TELECONFERENCE WAITING TO
TESTIFY. IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
ARE IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL THAT
ONLINE FORTY SIX. THE OWNER SO
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER. OUR POSITION IS THE
RESPECTFUL OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED BECAUSE THE FUNDING IN
THE BILL- PROVIDE ALL UP ONLY
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR- UNION ONLY
PRE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM AND
EXCLUDE- EIGHTY NOR CAL PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM- WHERE
IN SUPPORT OF- INVESTING IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT HELP.
FOLKS AND LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
ABC NOR CAL MEMBERS INCLUDE
LOCAL MINORITY WOMEN DON'T
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYER ARE READY
WILLING AND ABLE TO BUILD
CALIFORNIA'S UNITY AND YOU NEED
AT NOW WE ARE- THE WORKER IN A
FORTY OUT ON BOTH ENDS THAT.
UNFORTUNATELY THE I WOULD AN
BILL THAT. FUND FOR PRE OF FOR
LIMIT BUT- RENTS ARE PROGRAM
THAT FOLLOW THE MALL CRAFT FOR
CURRICULUM WHICH IS A
CURRICULUM THAT MICHAEL ARE
PROHIBITED FROM PARTICIPATING
ARE YOU USING WE USE- OF
CURRICULUM. PRODUCED BY THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR
CONSTRUCTION EDUCATION AND
RESEARCH WHICH IS ALSO USED BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH THEM IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
ONE MINUTE THEY ROBUST
LEGITIMATE STRONG CURRICULUM
AND- ME WOULD- OF THE OFFER AND
IT NEEDED. TO EXPAND HER. ALLOW
FOR THE PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM YOU ALSO ASK THAT THAT
FUNDING IN ORDER TO HELP
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CONSTRUCTION IN THE STATE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITH
THAT AS THREE MINUTES THIS
OPPOSITION FURTHER ADDITIONAL
APPOINTMENTS IN THE
TELECONFERENCE Q. YEAH FOR THAT
ONLINE SIXTY ONE. GOOD MORNING
SENATORS THIS IS WHAT GOOD
MORNING SENATORS IS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION AND THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS. ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE POSITION STATED BY MR
ON. THANK YOU OUR NEXT OPPONENT
IN A TELECONFERENCE Q. ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THAT TIME. AND THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE OKAY
COULD YOU DO ONE FINAL CALL
PLEASE. SURE YOUR IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE ZERO. THERE'S NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY WE WILL THEN
BRING THIS BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE- ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE COMMENTS WERE FIRST
RECOGNIZE A SENATOR WHY KELSEY
IF YOU COULD PLEASE MAKE SURE
TURN YOUR MICROPHONE ON. WHEN
YOU SPEAK. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR ARM I HAVE A QUESTION
REGARDING THE STRUCTURE OF THE
PROGRAM- THE HUNDRED NINETY
FIVE PER MILLION THAT GOES FOR
FIVE YEARS TO GO BE IS TO CLIMB
IT- ADAPTATION WORK ON SEA
LEVEL RISE. FLOOD PROTECTION
WILDFIRES AND THE LIKE OVER THE
LAST. FOR FIVE YEARS OUR
CLIMATE ADAPTATION PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN GOING TO THE OFFICE
OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH FOR
THE UMBRELLA GROUP WITH THE
GOVERNOR THAT THEY AND DISTRICT
WHICH HOUSES THE SEARCH FEATURE
GROWTH COUNCIL WHICH HAS BEEN
DOING THE PLANNING WORK. THAT
WERE YOU KNOW. PROMOTING STRONG
NEIGHBORHOODS CONVERTING VACANT
LAND SO WHY ARE WE MOVING. THE
MONEY INTO GO BE AS RATHER THAN
FULL PR WHICH HAS BEEN DOING
THIS WORK AND SORT OF HAS AN
IDEA OF WHERE TH PLANET. THE
PLANNING PROCESS IS IN ALL
THESE DIFFERENT. JURISDICTIONS
THAT'S MY QUESTION. OKAY I
SENATOR BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RESPOND. OF ALL CONSIDER ANY-
DEPARTMENT THAT'S INTERESTED IN
THIS PROGRAM BUT- ESSENTIALLY
GO BILL IS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT- DEPARTMENT- THAT
IS SITUATED TO- PROVIDE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT- GRANTS
AND MATCHING FUNDS TO- FUN-
THOSE KINDS OF PROGRAMS. THAT
STIMULATE- CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION AND THERE'S WHEN YOU
SAY CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
THERE'S A WIDE. VARIETY OF
TYPES OF FUN SO THAT'S THE
REASON THEY CERTAINLY WILL WORK
WITH- THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH AND- CONDUCTING- THAT
PROGRAM I GAVE BECAUSE THE
POINT MISTER CHAIRS AT ALL THE
AGENCIES IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA'S SUPPOSED TO BE
WORKING ON CLIMATE CHANGE IN
CLIMATE ADAPTATION CALTRANS-
PART OF HOUSING HEALTH HUMAN
SERVICES HE ADDED THAT IT DOT
AT THE HARMONIZING ELEMENT IS
FULL PR WHICH HAS THAT
OVERSIGHT OVER ALL OF THEM SO
WHAT. I'M CONCERNED WITH IS
THAT YOU JUST GET A PATCH OF
MONEY TO GO BE AS THEY MADE IN
THEIR BASS MINE MAY WANT TO
PROMOTE STRONG NEIGHBORHOODS
BUT THEY HAVEN'T DONE THE
PLANNING THAT OPR AND SHE'S
FECAL GROWTH COUNCIL HAS SORT
OF SAID THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK
BETTER NOT THAT'S NOT IT MAY BE
MORE HOUSES YOU PUTTING
FLOODPLAIN THAT'S THAT'S MY
POINT- THE OTHER. QUESTION I
HAVE IS YOU KNOW IT'S ISSUES
IT'S TWO BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
WE'RE CUTTING SOMETHING MY
CONCERN IS THESE ARE EXISTING
PROGRAMS WITH THE NEW PER WITH
NEW CHARACTERS IN I'VE DONE
SOME WORK IN THE EIGHTY YOU
ARE. AREA THERE'S NO SPECIFIC
PROGRAM THAT MIGHT HELP OUT
SMALL HOMEOWNERS THAT WOULD
LIKE TO BUILD THE UNIT IN THERE
IN THEIR BACK YARD OR WITH THE
CARE. GIVER ANY ANY MAN BUT OF
IT SO BUT I THINK THAT THE
WHERE THE IF THE GOAL HERE IS
TO RELATE CHEN AND YOU. WOULD
LIKE INCLUDE EVERYBODY EVEN THE
NEW PRODUCTS THAT AND THE
COURTS I HOPE THE. THIRTY LOOK
AT. NO GRAHAM GIVE BEEN SET FOR
PEOPLE TO THANKS FOR DELYLAH
UNITS VERY CAL IS ONE OF THE
PER HIS SOME WORK TRYING TO
WORD OUT TO HELP PEOPLE THEIR
THE OF IT AND THAT'S- AN AREA.
AGAIN THE OTHER THING THE OTHER
CONCERN THAT I HAVE AND A GOOD
JUST GO TO COPE IS BUT I'M VERY
CONCERNED WITH THE WEALTHY.
INTERFACE AND NO. PROTECTIONS
OR LIMITATIONS ON CONSTRUCTION
IN THOSE AREAS YES WE- AS WE
CONTINUE CONTINUE TO BATTLE THE
PANDEMIC AND CLIMATE CHANGE SO
THERE'S A- THERE'S- WHILE
PEOPLE MAY WANT TO MONEY FOR
ECONOMIC STIMULUS IT MAYBE
BUILDING HOUSES IN THE EXACT
AREAS WE DON'T WANT THEM TO BE.
BUILT AND WE HAVE DONE THAT
THAT WORK AND AT THAT CHALLENGE
SO- I'LL LEAVE IT AT THAT
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER ACCOUNTS THE NEXT
CENTER MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR VERY GRATEFUL I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE A QUICK MOMENT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
BELL. CENTRE BELL HAS BEEN
WORKING ON ALL ISSUES OF
HOUSING HIS ENTIRE CAREER IN
THE LEGISLATURE. SB SEVEN
NINETY FIVE IS CRITICAL
CRITICAL TO BE ABLE TO SOLVE
OUR CRISIS IN THIS IS BE CANDID
AT THE CRISIS IS MORE CUTE THAN
EVER BEFORE THE REASON I SAY
THAT IS WHAT THIS VIRUS IS DONE
IS SHOWN THE DISPARITY IN OUR
ECONOMY. DISPARITY IN OUR
HOUSING MARKET FOR THOSE HAVE
IN THOSE WHO HAVE NOT I KNOW
THAT HE'S GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL CONTINUE TO
WORK DETAILS OUT WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS. AND IT'S ONE
TECHNO MISTER CHAIR AGAIN IS A
THANK YOU TO THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM SAN JOSE FOR HIS TENACIOUS
WORK. THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
AYE NEXT WITH A CENTER MORE
LOCK. THANK YOU MISTER OF
CENTRE BELL OF LAST YEAR YOU
DID A SIMILAR BILL IT WAS
VETOED BY THE GOVERNOR I JUST
WAS CURIOUS IF YOU COULD
COMMENT. ON WHAT'S DIFFERENT
THIS YEAR. I WOULD SAY WHAT'S
DIFFERENT THIS YEAR AS WE HAVE
OF A EVEN MORE EXTREME CRISIS.
WITH PROVIDING HOUSING. DUE TO
THE VIRUS DUE TO. THE ECONOMICS
IN CALIFORNIA THE UNEMPLOYMENT
CALIFORNIA AND TO DO NOTHING.
JUST DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE. TO
DO NOTHING MEANS THAT WE'LL
HAVE MORE HOMELESS MORE
GOVERNMENT COST. MORE TRAGEDIES
IN FAMILIES TO DO NOTHING MEANS
THAT. THE PROBLEMS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE. WITH THEIR HOUSING. WILL
BE IGNORED BY THE LEGISLATURE.
SO I THINK THE SENATE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN STRONGLY SUPPORT OF.
PROGRAMS TO DEVELOP A PACKAGE
OF BILLS. OUR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND HOUSING PRODUCTION
AND WE HAVE A HOUSING
PRODUCTION BILL- HERE THAT WILL
PRODUCE CONSTRUCTION OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING YOU'LL
PROVIDE ECONOMIC STIMULUS. AND
MORE THAN ANY OTHER TIME WE
NEED TO CREATE THESE JOBS. IT
SEEMS TO ME THAT NOW'S THE TIME
TO DO IT MORE THAN EVER. SO IT
WAS VETOED IN AN ERA OF SURPLUS.
AND NOW WE'RE IN AN ERA OF A
DEFICIT I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS DO
YOU HAVE. ANY INSIGHTS AS TO
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S THINKING
ABOUT THIS PROGRAM WELL I WOULD
READ THE DETAILED MESSAGE WHICH
STATES THAT- IN IN. TERMS OF-
PREVIOUS VETOES HE EXCLAIMED
THAT. WE SHOULD CONSIDER THIS
BOTH IN TERMS OF POLICY BUT
ALSO IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET
THAT'S WITH THE GOVERNOR'S VETO
MESSAGE SAID IF YOU READ IT
THAT'S THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT HE
SAID. SO WE ARE DOING NOW ALL
RIGHT THAT IS JUST SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER BOTH AS A POLICY ISSUE
WHICH WE ARE TODAY. BUT ALSO.
WHEN IT COMES TIME TO.
DEVELOPING ANY KIND OF CREATIVE
FINANCING. WE SHOULD NOT GIVE
UP WE SHOULD CONTINUE. WE
SHOULD TRY TO HELP PEOPLE. THAT
ARE SUFFERING. THERE'S MORE
MORE HOMELESS. THERE'S MORE AND
MORE NEED- THE GOVERNOR IS-
SHIFTING HIS POSITION FROM
WHERE HE WAS LAST YEAR. AND SO
SHOULD WE- THANK YOU CENTER
BELT THANK YOU MISTER. CENTER
TO ROSS SO. UP THANK YOU I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. I TO
WANT TO A SKEWS ME APPLIED
SENATOR BELL OF FOR PUSHING FOR
A LONG TERM FUNDING STRATEGY-
VERSES THE JUST ONE OFF. THIS
MUCH MONEY THIS YEAR YOU REALLY
CAN'T DEPEND ON JUST. ONE AT A
TIME WHEN YOU'RE AT A TIME I
ESPECIALLY. APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE PRIORITIZING MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND FARM WORKER HOUSING
AND I BELIEVE AS THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE SHOULD BE
COMMITTED. TO PROTECTING AND
CREATING HOUSING FOR THE
COMMUNITIES WITH THE MOST NEEDS
ADD UP YOUR BILL DOES JUST THAT
I ALSO ONE APPLAUD YOU FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE WAY IN WHICH ALL
OF THESE PIECES ARE PULLED
TOGETHER- BUSINESS SEES AS AS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY. OF WORKERS
SEE THIS THAT THEY'LL BE PAID
OF DECENT GOOD WAGES- SO I
AGAIN I APPLAUD YOU FOR THE
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH OF THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN WITH THIS- I JUST
HAVE ONE. OF THE ISSUE WHICH I
MENTIONED TO YOU WHICH IS THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY. I AND PRE
APPRENTICES PRE APPRENTICESHIPS
I DO BELIEVE THAT A THIS TIME
WHAT NEEDS TO MATCH THE URGENCY
AND THE BIGGER SCALE THAT WERE
THINKING ABOUT THAT YOU'VE
PROPOSED HERE THAT WE HAVE TO
BE MUCH MUCH MORE ASSERTIVE.
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF MEN AND
WOMEN WHO CAN GET THROUGH- THE
APPRENTICESHIP PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND BE
A PART OF THAT SKILLED WORK
FORCE OF AND GOOD WAGES SO I
WOULD URGE- THE SENATOR TO.
INCREASE THE AMOUNT TOWARDS ALL
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER LIKE
HEALTHCARE I'M SORRY I FORGOT
TO QUESTION PICKING UP ON WITH
US SENATE TO RISE SO JUST SAID
THE- OPPOSITION WHO IS A
RELATIVELY IS INTERESTED IN
CREATING GOOD JOBS TO IS SAYING
THAT THE CURRICULUM THAT THEY
USE. IN THEIR PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IS THE
SAME THAT WE USE IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO DOES THAT
MEAN THAT IF I GRADUATE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WITH THE-
CONSTRUCTION. DEGREE I'M NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING FOR THE
JOE SERRANO PROGRAM OR THE
HOUSING TRUST FUND OR ANY OF
THESE PROGRAMS AS THE BILL'S
WRITTEN RIGHT NOW. IS THAT THE
QUESTION MISTER CHAIR TO THE
AUTHOR. SENATE BILL OF. I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
CURRICULUM. THAT'S DEVELOPED BY
THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD
THERE THE ONES THAT HAVE THE
TECHNICAL SKILLS AND ABILITIES
TO DEVELOP- THE CURRICULUM AND
WE'RE SIMPLY SAYING. THAT THE
ALLOCATION THAT GOES TO THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD WILL
BE IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
APPROVED TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT
THEY HAVE ADOPTED AS APPROVED
PROGRAMS. THESE OTHER PROGRAMS
IF THEY WANT TO- CAN. GET THEIR
CURRICULUM APPROVED THEY HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO THE
WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD AND-
THIS IS THE SAME- AS WE HAD
AND- SB ONE. I TAKE I TAKE THIS
IS THE REASON THAT THIS EVEN IS
IN THE BILL IS BECAUSE WE SIR
RECOGNIZE THAT IF WE'RE GOING
TO INCREASE HOUSING PRODUCTION
CONSTRUCTION. WE NEED TO HAVE
SKILLED IN TRADE WORKFORCE. AND
WE HAVE TO HAVE SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE OF INCREASES SO
THAT'S WHY. THIS IS ALLOCATION
IS IN THIS IN THIS BILL BUT-
THE BILL DOES NOT. ADJUST OR
CHANGE THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARDS PROCESS THROUGH.
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR AND THE
OTHER AGENCIES IN TERMS OF
CURRICULUM FOR- SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. MR IMAGES IF
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
CURRICULUM IS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WE GOT A BUNCH OF
THERE WERE TRYING TO PROMOTE
THIS IS A TIME WHEN YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE GOING BACK TO SCHOOL
TO LEARN THE SKILLS AND I WOULD
HATE TO SEE THAT THEY GET TO
TWO YEARS IN GRADUATE FROM
GAVEL HONOR SAN JOSE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND SAID- YOU GOT THE
WRONG CERTIFICATE YOU'RE NOT IT
DOESN'T APPLY TO SB SEVEN NINE
FIVE WHICH IS AGAIN I DON'T
KNOW I DON'T KNOW THE RIGORS OF
THE ALL THE DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
AND JUST SPOTTING AN ISSUE THAT
THAT MIGHT WANT SOME ATTENTION
IF WHICH REALLY TRYING TO-
SPREAD THAT BI AND BRAWL AND
GET GET STUFF CONSTRUCTED BUT-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- COLORS
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHO
HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
REGARDING SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE.
OKAY JUST BEFORE I TURN OVER
SAID ABOUT A CLOSE I WANT TO
THANKS- CENTER BELL FOR HIS
EXTRAORDINARY LEADERSHIP ON
FUNDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
YOU MAY RECALL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. HE AUTHORED- THE
BILL THAT FIVE CENT A
SIGNIFICANT AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BOND TO THE VOTERS WHICH A
VOTERS PASSED- AND HE HAS NOW
BEEN WORKING TIRELESSLY- TO
MAKE SURE THE CALIFORNIA. KEEPS
ITS COMMITMENTS- TO CREATE AND
THE FUNDS HOUSING FOR
PARTICULARLY OUR LOW INCOME.
VERY LOW INCOME EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME RESIDENTS. NINETEEN AS
IT HAS FOR MANY ISSUES HAS
SHED. A SPOTLIGHT HAS CAST A
SPOTLIGHT ON SOME OF THE
UGLIEST ASPECTS OF OUR SOCIETY.
AND THE OBSCENE COSTS OF
HOUSING. AND THE OBSCENE RATES
OF HOMELESSNESS IN CALIFORNIA.
ARE AMONG THOSE SCARS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE BEING
VIOLATED SADLY BY COVER
NINETEEN BUT IT'S ALSO GOOD TO
CAST A SPOTLIGHT BECAUSE IT
ALLOWS EVERYONE TO SEE WHAT IS
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN THE
STATE. AND IT CREATES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
ADDRESS. THAT PROBLEM WE KNOW
WE HAVE A TERRIBLE BUDGET
DEFICIT NOW. BUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FUNDING MUST BE PART OF
THE MIX AS WE GO THROUGH THIS
TERRIBLE BUDGET TIMES AND
INDEED AS YOU GO INTO A
RECESSION. IT MAKES EVEN MORE
SENSE TO INCREASE YOUR
INVESTMENT IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSIDERING THAT WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THE PRIVATE SECTOR.
DURING A RECESSION AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE KEEPING
OUR CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE
EMPLOYED SO WE DON'T HAVE A
REPEAT. OF TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT. WHERE THE
HELL THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
BASICALLY THE SALT AND OUR
CONSTRUCTION WORK FOR SCATTERED
TO THE FOUR CORNERS OF THE
EARTH E STILL HAVE NOT
RECOVERED. FROM OUR LOSS OF THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCE. FROM
THE LAST RECESSION LET'S NOT
HAVE THAT HAPPEN AGAIN. AND ONE
WAY WE CAN PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING. IS TO INVEST
AGGRESSIVELY IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SO WE CAN KEEP. OUR
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE EMPLOYED
IN YES THAT MEANS UNIONIZED
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AS WELL.
HI SO I AM PROUD TO CO AUTHOR-
THIS MEASURE- AND I AM
RECOMMENDING- AND I HAVE A
CENTER ABOUT AGAIN THANK YOU.
AND YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS- THIS BILL THIS
BILL- WILL PROVIDE. A INFUSION
INTO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY
SPECIFICALLY AT THE RIGHT TIME
AND THE RIGHT MOMENT THAT IS
NEEDED. IN TERMS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION AS WELL AS
SOLVE ONE OF THE VEXING- SOCIAL
PROBLEMS WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
HOW TO FUND ONGOING BASIS.
PROGRAMS FOR HOMELESSNESS-
CONSTRUCTION OF FACILITIES FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE HOMELESS THE
BILL ELIMINATE PAYING SOCIAL
TRAGEDY LIKE TO ANSWER A FEW
QUESTIONS- FIRST OF ALL OF THIS
THIS IS THE PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE HERE OR PRETTY MUCH
SEVERAL OF THE SAME PROGRAMS AS
FOR SIMPLICITY'S PURPOSES AS
WERE APPROVED BY THE VOTERS IN
PROPOSITION ONE THE BOND
PROGRAM THERE- SIMPLE. OF THE
STAFF IS OPERATING. THOSE PROP
ONE FUNDS THIS PROP ONE FUNDS
WILL BE. ALLOCATED AND THE NEXT
YEAR TWO TWO YEARS WILL BE GONE.
WE NEED TO HAVE A REPLACEMENT.
WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING- THE
COMES AFTER THAT. SO IF YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL.
UNDER PROPOSITION ONE APPROVED
BY THE VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF THOSE PROBLEMS
THE WORKFORCE INVESTMENT BOARD
ISSUE. WORKFORCE INVESTMENT
BOARD SHOULD RECEIVE MORE MONEY
YES THEY NEED MORE MONEY TO
DEVELOP ARE SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE NOW MORE THAN EVER
BECAUSE WE NEED PEOPLE TO BE
TRAINED AND GOOD PAYING JOBS SO
THEY CAN GET OFF PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE AND- FEED THEIR
FAMILIES RIGHT NOW THIS BILL IS
THE ONE BILL THAT PROVIDES
TRAINING. FUNDING THAT I'VE
SEEN TIMES ANY OTHER BILLS I
WOULD CITY. OTHER BILLS BY ANY
OTHER AGENCIES TO PROVIDE- JOB
TRAIN THE ONLY OTHER BUILDING
DID IT WAS SB ONE. WHICH
PROVIDE A FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR FOR FIVE YEARS AND EVEN
THAT WASN'T ENOUGH MONEY. SO OF
GOOD CENTER FOR LOS ANGELES IS
CORRECT WE NEED TO HAVE MORE.
FUNDING FOR SKILLED IN TRADE
PROGRAMS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAMS. THIS IS THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE HAVE HERE WILL NOT
VIOLATE ANY. LAND USE GENERAL
PLAN AND THEY HAVE TO BE
APPROVED BY THE CITY'S. THEY
WILL NOT ENCOURAGE I HAVEN'T
ENCOURAGE IN THE PAST SPRAWLING
DEVELOPMENT SO I DON'T THINK
THE THAT. IS A IS A GOING TO
HAPPEN WITH THIS. I ALSO THINK
THAT. THE PROGRAMS WE CAN LOOK
AT THE PROGRAMS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SMALL SCALE EIGHTY YOU
INVESTMENTS ARE ALLOWED WITH
SOME OF THE PROGRAMS I THINK
THAT. THAT IS- LOGICAL THING TO
DO WILL WORK ON THAT. WITH THE
GOOD CENTER FROM FREMONT. SO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN HERE
JOHN I WROTE ON THE MEASURE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
BELL- AND AGAIN I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL- SO DO WE HAVE A
MOTION ON SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE.
MOVE THE BILL. OKAY AND THERE
ARE NO AMENDMENTS- SO THAT BILL
IS A MOTION- TO SEND THIS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE-
THE CORRECT SERVICE. OKAY THEM
THE BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY
CENTER CABALLERO AND SECRETARY
WILL CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SEVEN NINETY FIVE
BY SENATOR BILL THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER. BY WIENER AYE
MORRELL. MORRELL NO CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO HI TO RAZA HI
DORADO HI MCGUIRE. MORE LOOK NO
MORE LUCK NO ROTH ROTH HI ROTH
HI SKINNER. SKINNER HI NUMBER.
CASCADE HI CASKEY I. SIX TWO
ARE THE VOTERS SIXTY TWO WE'RE
GOING TO HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
CENTER MICHAEL I WILL BE
RETURNING AND CENTER ON BURKE
WILL BE HERE IN A LITTLE WHILE
SO THE ROLE IS OPEN BUT IT DOES
HAVE ENOUGH VOTES. TO PASS.
OKAY WE WILL NEXT- GO TO ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT NINETY NINE
ON THE AUTHOR OF A SPEED NINE
NINE SO I WILL TURN OVER- NOT
PHYSICALLY. BUT FIGURATIVELY
TURN OVER THE- GAVEL TO- OUR
VICE CHAIR CENTER- MORALE. OKAY
WELCOME CENTER- HOPE YOU'RE
DOING WELL TODAY AND- IF YOU'RE
READY PLEASE PRESENT SB- EIGHT
NINETY NINE. I THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND I'M DOING GREAT
I HOPE YOUR AS WELL. MY
COLLEAGUES I SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY NINE. IS AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING BILLS. THAT MAKES
CERTAIN TYPES OF UNDER UTILIZED
LAND. SPECIFICALLY LAND THAT IS
OWNED BY NONPROFIT HOSPITALS.
NONPROFIT COLLEGE. COLLEGES
AND- NONPROFIT THOUGHT FAIH
BASED ORGANIZATIONS. AVAILABLE
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT- TO BE CLEAR THIS
BILL IS LIMITED TO ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT. SUBSIDIZE BELOW MARKET
RATE. OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE BILL IS CO SPONSORED BY THE
TWO LARGEST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COALITION. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
NONPROFIT HOUSING. OR SCAM AND
THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND PH. UNDER SB
8991100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS WILL BE PERMITTED
UNDER ZONING AND STREAMLINED.
IF THEY'RE BUILT ON LANDS OWNED
BY ONE OF THE AFOREMENTIONED
NONPROFITS AND AB CERTAIN
CRITERIA SO THAT THEY- ARE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE GIVEN
NEIGHBORHOOD. FOR EXAMPLE A
DEVELOPMENT LOCAL LOCATED IN A
RESIDENTIAL SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOOD- IT CAN BE UP TO
THREE STORIES TALL- OR THE
LOCAL HEAD OF THE LOCAL IT IS
TALLER- AND A DEVELOPMENTS IN A
MIXED USE A COMMERCIAL AREA.
CAN BE UP TO FIVE STORIES TALL
UNLESS A LOCAL HAVEN THAT. IS
TALLER. IT WOULD BE PRICES ARE
CHARGED FOR THESE AFFORDABLE
UNITS WHICH MUST BE DEED
RESTRICTED. I MUST BE ON
AVERAGE AFFORDABLE TO PEOPLE
THAT MEET DEFINITION. OF LOW
INCOME VERY LOW INCOME OR
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME THE
AVERAGE JUST BE NO HIGHER THAN
80% OF THE AREA MEDIAN INCOME.
CONSISTENT WITH FEDERAL AND
STATE FAIR HOUSING LAW EVERY
HOUSING UNIT IN ITS DEVELOPMENT
MUST NOT DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
ANY PROTECT THE CLASS. QUITTING
RACE ETHNICITY. AND SO FORTH.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT BY
THIS TURNER CENTER AT BERKELEY
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
COUNTIES OF ALAMEDA LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO AND SAN
FRANCISCO THOSE FIVE COUNTIES
ALONE. HAVE MORE THAN TEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF DEVELOPER
WILL LAND. THE COULD BE USED
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT SO WE LOOK AT THE
SCALE OF WHAT COULD BE
DEVELOPED OVER TIME. WITH THE
ACCESS LAND OWNED BY THESE
NONPROFITS IT COULD LEAD TO A
HUGE AMOUNT OF NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I'M GRATEFUL- TO THE
ENGAGEMENT OF MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
THE BILL. I SPECIFICALLY I
WANNA I MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE
BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
CENTER LIKE HOUSE KIAN CENTER
ROTH INNER COMMITTING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY THAT WE
WILL TAKE IN THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ONE- IT CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE HAVE DONE IN OTHER
BILLS TWO EXAMS- THE VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD AREAS. FROM THE
BILL THAT'S CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER HOUSING BILLS THAT WE
HAVE- AUTHORED AND PASSED. ON
AS WELL AS PUTTING LANGUAGE
THAT QUALIFIES YOU HOUSING
BUILDING HIGH LOCAL SAFETY
CONCERNS. SUCH AS ENSURING THAT
LOCAL FIRE DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE
RIGHT MAN TO BE ABLE TO GO UP
HIGH ENOUGH. TO PUT OUT A FIRE.
IT IN. I ALL RIGHT. WORK THIS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE AND PARTNER
CENTER THIS BILL ALL RIGHT HEY
WE BEEN IN THIS COMPANY
CIRCUMVENT OULD HAVE BEEN
REFER TO THE GOVERNANCE FINANCE
COMMITTEE WERE ONLY DOING
SINGLE REFERRALS ALL BE WORKING
WITH SENATE MCGUIRE GOING
FORWARD- TO TALK ABOUT AN
ADDRESS- VARIOUS- IS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE BEST STRONGEST
POSSIBLE. HELLO CALIFORNIA IS
IN A DEEP HOUSING CRISIS. AND A
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF THAT
CRISIS HAS TO DO WITH HOUSING
FOR WORKING CLASS LOW INCOME.
RESIDENTS WE NEED TO DO MORE
THIS BILL WILL DO MORE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL.
TESTIFYING WITH ME TODAY OR-
TEACHER- GO BY FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. ONE OF OUR
SPONSORS AND ROB BY NORTH PARK
THIS FROM THE VALLEY FROM THE
BELLY BEST SHALOM SYNAGOGUE IN
LOS ANGELES. OKAY WE WILL- NOW
MOVE IN- TO ANYONE WANTING TO
TESTIFY IN PLEASE AS A REMINDER.
EACH SIDE WILL ONLY BE
PERMITTED OF TOTAL THREE
MINUTES ALL OTHERS WAS SEEN
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE. SOUL ANY BUT HE HAD
LIKE TO SPEAK- AGAIN A TOTAL
KIM IS HAVE A THREE MINUTES
PLEASE. GREAT GOOD MORNING VICE
CHAIR MORAL AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PATRICK
I'M CALLING ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR AT THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE ARE FORTY YEAR
OLD PORTABLE HOUSING AND
BECAUSE YOUR CONDITION WHOSE
MISSION IS TO FIGHT FOR FUTURE
WORK EVERYONE IN THE BAY AREA
HAS A STABLE AND AFFORDABLE
PLACE TO CALL HOME. THANK YOU
YOU H. LONG WORK OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTERPART CAMP ARE
PROUD TO CLOSE OUR CROWD
COSPONSORED SB EIGHT NINETY
NINE AS IT IS A CRITICAL
PRIORITY. FOR THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMMUNITY WILL HELP OUR
STATE FUNDAMENTALLY ATTRACT ARE
PORTABLE HOUSING EMERGENCY. BY
OPENING UP TO SITES OWNED BY
SPEAKING. NONPROFIT HOSPITALS
AND NONPROFIT COLLEGES TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
AND GREATLY SIMPLIFIED THE
PROCESS. OFTEN THE ONLY WAY TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING ANY
BEHIND THAT COLD. CALIFORNIANS
BEST SCHOOLS AND SERVICES. THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH A WITH A FAITH
COMMUNITY. ACTUALLY EIGHT
THIRTY NINE FORTY AND ASSIST ON
A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN EIGHTEEN
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPERS. MAKING IT EASIER TO
BUILD. OKAY. FIND THE PROCESS
IN THE. WHERE THEY OPERATE BILL
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIANS FAMILIES SENIORS
PEOPLE CAN REALLY BE AND BETTER
AND TO BE ABLE TO FIND AN
AFFORDABLE PLACE TO CALL HOME.
ACTUALLY NEEDED NOW IN THE
MIDST OF THE- GLOBAL PANDEMIC
THAT IS WHY I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR IPHONE TODAY THANK
YOU. ANOTHER WITNESS TO TESTIFY
PLEASE. THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS RABBI NO OF MARKETS
AND I SERVE MY COMMUNITY VALLEY
THIS WOMAN LOOKED ANGELES BY
LARGEST JEWISH COMMUNITY
INSTITUTION IN THE SAN FERNANDO
VALLEY WITH OVER TEN THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WHO CRAVE LEARN IN
ACT WITH LOVE TOGETHER. IN THE
PAST CHAIRPERSON OF THE LOS
ANGELES HOMELESS SERVICES
AUTHORITY TO CURRENTLY THE
CHAIR OF THE FINANCE COMMITTEE
ALTHOUGH I'M NOT HERE AND THAT
OFFICIAL. ACTIVITY WE VALLEY
NATIONAL- HAVE A LARGE PARKING
LOT BY THE THIRTY BLACK LOCATED
JUST OFF AND TERRIBLE THE BARD.
THE PINT A PANDEMIC IT WITH
SCHOOL EVERY DAY WITH CARS FOR
PICK UP AND DROP OFF ONE FOUR
SCHOOLS FOR FOOD BANK IN
COUNSELING CENTER AND LEARNING
WORSHIP AND FELLOWSHIP
OPPORTUNITY. WELL WE ARE
FORTUNATE A VIBRANT COMMUNITY
WE LIKE MANY OTHER COMMUNITY
BECAUSE- AT THIS PARKING LOT
IT'S BILL UNDER UTILIZED. WE
ARE LAND RICH BUT CASH OR AS WE
WOULD LIKE TO ASK SUCH WE'D
LIKE TO DEVELOP THE PROPERTY
INTO A WELL HOUSING FOR SENIORS
AND I. SWEAR PLEASED BY THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND THE
IMPENDING AT. RIGHT WE CAN
AFFORD TO DO SO. BECAUSE OF THE
ALLOCATED COSTS TO DEVELOP. AT
EIGHT NINETY NINE IS WHAT I
BELIEVE THEY COULD FAITH
ATTEMPT TO BRING TOGETHER
ALLIES FROM ACROSS THE
POLITICAL AND ECONOMIC
SPECTRUM. TO ADDRESS THE
HOUSING CRISIS AND NOW THE
ECONOMIC RIGHT YOU TO CALL THE
NINETEEN. MANY CHURCHES ARE
DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
HELP PARISHIONERS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND OTHER COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS OF THE THING HOW DO
YOU HOW DO YOU KNOW HOW THE
WORSE IF. I LEADING THEM UP
CREDIT FOR. IN UP HERE THAN
OTHERS RECALL RIGHT STREAMS
VULNERABLE. PLEASE. CREATE
RELATIONSHIPS. I ALL
COMMUNITIES. HIRED TO PASS THE
BILL SO THEY COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE CAN CONTRIBUTE TO WHAT
MAKE CALIFORNIA THE MOST
COMPASSIONATE STATE IN THE
UNION I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
GALLERY AGAIN ARE AT THIS POINT
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR- COMMENTS TO
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION POSITION
ON THIS MEASURE. ANY IN THE
GALLERY. BEFORE BY ONE. THE
DIFFICULTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PART SO SEE ASIAN IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU NEXT. BRIAN ADDRESSED
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION AND WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO OH FOR
ALL WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. NOT A OKAY. THANK YOU
LET'S MOVE THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE-
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE PLEASE.
BOMBS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROPERTY INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TESTIFY- IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT NINETY NINE. AND WILL
BEGIN AND BY THE WAY HOW MANY.
ARE IN THE QUEUE. RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE TEN TEN OKAY FAR AWAY IN
AGAIN- PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU. OKAY WE
WILL BEGIN WITH A LINE TWENTY
EIGHT. GOOD MORNING- THIS IS
AFTER AND GOT A YOUR WITH
BURBANK HOUSING I STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT SB EIGHT NINE NINE.
THANK YOU. NEXT FILL THAT
ONLINE FIFTY SIX. IT MAY FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING THE
COURT. NEXT LINE TWENTY FOUR.
GO AHEAD LINE TWENTY FOUR. LIKE
SEVERAL OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP IN SUPPORT.
NEXT DEADLINE SEVENTY FIVE.
COREY SMITH WITH THE BAY AREA
HELPING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT SB EIGHT. NEXT LINE
SIXTY SEVEN. LOUIS MARIN'S WITH
CALIFORNIAN BE IN SUPPORT.
NECKLINE SIXTY TWO. WE CANNOT
FAILING ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY BUILDERS IN SUPPORT.
NECKLINE FORTY NINE. GO AHEAD
NINE FORTY NINE. ARE YOU I MEAN.
OVER THE NEXT NINE EIGHTY FOUR.
DAVID KING KHAN ON BEHALF OF
TACO NONPROFIT HUSING PROVIDER
AT THE GROUP IN SUPPORT. NEXT
AND THIRTY EIGHT. THIS IS FRANK
MARTINEZ FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
NONPROFIT HOUSING HERE A CO
SPONSOR AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ALL NEXT DEADLINE
SEVENTEEN. THIS IS MARIANN LAMB
ON BEHALF OF THE H. HOUSING AND
STRONGER. ON SUPPORT. NEXT
DEADLINE FORTY FIVE. THIS IS
SERRA LEADS FROM HOLLYWOOD
COMMUNITY HOUSING CORPORATION
AND WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT IN
SB EIGHT NINE NINE. NEXT
DEADLINE SIXTY SIX. GO AHEAD
LINE SIXTY SIX. I THOUGHT MY
ERA ON BEHALF OF THE UNITY
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
DEADLINE FORTY FOUR. STILL THE
IDEAL ARE ON BEHALF OF THE TWO
HUNDRED IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
EIGHT NINETY NINE. NEXT IS AN
EIGHTY THREE. LOCAL LOCAL
COMPLICATED CALIFORNIA AND MARK
THANK. THE LINE. NEXT HEADLINE
THIRTY FIVE. GO AHEAD LINE
THIRTY FIVE. YOU HAVE A
COMMUNITY. EIGHT NINE NINE
THANK GOD NINE FORTY YOU'LL
HAVE TO SAY THAT AGAIN. HI MY
NAME IS ALLEY CANNING CAN AND
I'M WITH THE HEALTH WEEK
BALLERINA APPLICATION FOR
DISABILITY IN PRINT THAT
HOUSING AND SUPPORT IN THE
EIGHT. NEXT WE LOOK AT ONLINE
TWENTY SEVEN. JIM WARREN
MOTIVATE THE ACTION COALITION
HELD A CHILDREN CONTRA COSTA
COUNTY. OR SB EIGHT NINE. NEXT
I GOT A LINE FIFTY FIVE. NINE
FIFTY FIVE ARE YOU A MUTE. WELL
GO TO THE NEXT NINE SIXTEEN.
GOOD MORNING BILL THE FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. NEXT TO WORK ON A LINE
THIRTY THREE. GO AHEAD LINE
THIRTY THREE. ARE YOU I MEAN IT.
BECAUSE THE NEXT LINE NIGHTLINE
TWENTY NINE. IT IS TO PLAY LOS
FELIZ EAST ASIAN LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION IT'S A
COURT. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
EIGHT. HELLO MEGAN ABLE WITH
CORRECTLY COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT DEADLINE
EIGHTY NINE. HELLO THIS IS ABBY
TRAINING WOULD PREPARE AREA
COUNCIL CALLING IN SUPPORT. AND
IF THERE'S ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. NEXT CALL THAT A LINE
FIFTY FIVE. GO AHEAD NINE FIFTY
FIVE. WELL IF TO HONOR ON
BEHALF OF THE SILICON VALLEY
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
YEAH NEXT CALL THAT A LINE
THIRTY THREE IS WITH HIM. NINE
THIRTY THREE GO I HAD. ALTHOUGH
THE NEXT LINE EIGHTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING CENTERS MY NAME IS THE
LACK OF THE CLAIM CALLING IT
THE COURT FOR SB EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE ON BEHIND ON BEHALF OF THE
THREE PEAT COALITION WHICH
INCLUDES SILICON VALLEY AT HOME
THE SAN FRANCISCO FOUNDATION
PMB PARTNERS AND SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA PLANNING AND URBAN
RESEARCH ASSOCIATION JUST TO
NAME A FEW. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL GO TWENTY SIX. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CAROLING ON BEHALF OF MARYLAND
AND BREED AND CITY AND COUNTY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MORNING THANK YOU.
AND THERE'S NO ONE OUT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CHECK THE LINE ONCE
AGAIN TO MAKE SURE WE'VE HEARD
FROM ALL SUPPORT WITNESSES ON.
SB EIGHT KNOW YOUR MIND APART
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THAT TIME.
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR IF
YOU'LL PLEASE- THANK YOU FOR
THAT IF THERE ARE NO MORE. SAY
THAT AGAIN ONE MORE THAT. APPLY
THIRTY THREE. GO AHEAD LINE.
YES JILL SHOOK WITH MAKING
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY HAPPEN
AND THIS IS A WE HAVE VERY MUCH
SUPPORT THAT POWERFUL WAY TO
PROVIDE A STATE MUCH NEEDED TO
GET THE JOB DONE THANK YOU. AND
THERE IS NO ONE OUT TO MAKE YOU.
FOR MORE. KATE MATTHEW. YOUR
MUTED. HOLLY FOR MEANING WHAT
MIGHT HAVE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CAP
CALIFORNIA AND THE PART OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE
OUT TO MAKE YOU. OKAY HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SIDES SUPPORTERS
WE WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY
OPPOSITION PLEASE. AND WILL
BEGIN. WITH WITNESSES HERE IN A
GALLERY IN OPPOSITION. OKAY ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO
OH FOR ALL WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE. TWENTY FIVE. I
KNOW. OKAY MA MODERATOR THANK
YOU GUYS IF WILL MOVE NOW MOVE
ON THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE THAT TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION IT TO BE A- NAY NINE
WILL BEGIN. APR IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
WILL GO TO LINE NINETEEN. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN MEDICARE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION WE
GOT OUR OPPOSE LETTER AROUND-
LATE YESTERDAY- BUT WE WANTED
TO RAISE A FEW ISSUES- WITH
THIS BILL AND REALLY. CHOOSE
WITH WE PICK IT WHERE OVER THE
YEARS ON ALL BILLS THANK YOU
BOB BYE RIGHT. WELL I LIKE TO
MAKE SURE I POINT OUT- THE
ANALYSIS- CONTAINS SOME
CONCERNS THAT WE AGREE WITH ALL
FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE- REGARDING PROJECT
SIZE RESTRICTIONS LOCATION
RESTRICTIONS IN THE LACK
THEREOF. AND THE CONCERN ABOUT
EIGHT ENCOUNTERING
ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
ISSUES- THAT- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT. TO THE CONSTRUCTION
AND COMES TO. ISSUES WE ARE
MARK. ENSURE THAT WE CAN YOU
SEE GLASS AND THE PROCESS TO
ENSURE THAT JOB SITE ARE NOT-
ENVIRONMENTALLY DANGEROUS FOR
THE WORKERS ARE GONNA SHOW UP.
AND NOT ONLY MOVE IT AROUND AND
I'M COVER POSSIBLE TOXIC ISSUES
THAT THEY CAN BE EXPOSED TO-
BUT ALSO IS FOR THAT
NEIGHBORING COMMUNITY- WHEN
THAT WORK BEGINS TO HAPPEN- SO
DOES LEAVE SHARE THOSE CONCERNS
OF THE VINYL QUALITY CANADIAN
WE ALSO I SHARE THE CAN IS
RATED BY THE OTHER AFTER MANY
AS WELL. AND THEN- WE ALSO LIKE
THAT YOU KNOW WE'VE ONLY THAT
THAT PREVAILING IN BUILDING. IS
NECESSITY ONE ONE EIGHT RANT.
BY TO FOR LESS LIMIT. COMMENT
TO. THREE MINUTES PLEASE. BUT I
DON'T KNOW I'D ALREADY PASSED
IN THE SEMINARY PASSED UNITS.
SO GO AHEAD REMEMBER THAT
THIRTY SILENCE IF YOU WOULD.
I'M I'M SORRY I CAN HEAR YOU
OVER THAT GO AHEAD THIRTY
SECONDS IF YOU WOULD PLEASE I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU. AS I SAID-
REQUIRING PREVAILING WAGES
GOLDEN TRAIN IN ANY BILL THAT
ARE INTENDED TO GRANT BY RIGHT-
TO DEVELOPERS WE THINK IS A
NECESSITY THOSE TWO GAMES NOT
ONLY PROVIDE TRAINING
OPPORTUNITIES. WITH SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND CONNECTIONS THERE IN
THE STATE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW BUT
DURING THIS RECESSION MIDDLE
CLASS WAGES AND BENEFITS. THAT
WILL SUSTAIN CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS MOVE. AS WE CLIMB OUT
OF PUBLIC ARE GOING TO BE A
GREAT TOUGH. FOR CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS WE AGREE WITH SENATOR
HERE'S HOW MUCH MORE AWARE
ABOUT PROVIDING. POSSIBLE
CONSTRUCTION WORKER THE
PREVAILING WAGE AND ADDING
SKILLED TRAINWRECK TO BUY RIGHT
BILLS PROVIDE A LOT SO WE
AREN'T RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANYONE
ELSE OF AN ONLINE I LINE EIGHTY
TWO. YES THIS IS MY QUEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
MACBOOK ADELINE SIXTY FIVE. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON ON THE
AFTER THE TEAMSTERS RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION I APOLOGIZE. YOU GET
A LETTER ON FILE. AT THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- MACRANTHA JOHN GAP THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFLICT OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS- WE WOULD
ALSO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
BUILDING TRADE IN OUR HEARING
LATE RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
THANK AND NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
ONE. GOOD MORNING MIKE BONTA
GONNA BE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE I
TRADE CANCEL WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
WE ARE OPPOSED UNLESS THE BILL
AS AMENDED TO INCLUDE LABOR
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU. AND IF
THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE. COULD YOU A CHECK
ONE MORE TIME OUR MODERATOR.
CHECK IF YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OKAY IF THERE ARE NO MORE
WITNESSES WANT TO THANK YOU ALL
FOR YOUR SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION-
WE WILL NOW BRING THE SESSION
BACK TO THE MEMBERS PLACE. DO
ANY OF OUR MEMBERS HAVE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
Y. KASKI. YES THINKING MISTER
VICE CHAIR I WAS LOOKING AT A
WERE BASE TEN SOCIETY IN THAT
YEAR WELL THE ALLOWANCES THIRTY
FIVE UNITS PER ACRE AND I WAS
WONDERING IF HE WOULD CONSIDER
A FRIENDLY AMENDMENT TO MAKE
THAT THIRTY SIX UNITS PER ACRE
A SET OF A QUARTER ACRE DIVIDES
NATURALLY AND NINE WHICH WOULD
ALLOW FIVE PARKING SPOTS IN A
PODIUM PARKING. THE
CONFIGURATION THAT WE GO IN IT
MAY BE EASIER FOR ADVOCATES
INSTEAD OF A POINT EIGHT UNITS
PER PER PER ACRE OR PER QUARTER
RECORD THAT YOU GET IN SO
THAT'S JUST A FRIENDLY.
AMENDMENT ARE A SUGGESTION. N.
LIKE WISE I KNOW THAT WHEN I
WAS ON THE PLANNING COMMISSION
BACK IN FREMONT EVERYBODY LIKES
A TEN FOOT HIGH. TRACK HOME
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIA
BUILD BART BUT WHAT THAT OR TEN
FOOT. PER A STORY AND THAT
CREATES AN EIGHT FOOT CEILINGS
AND WE'VE LEARNED IN THE WITH
THE- WITH RENOVATIONS PEOPLE TO
IS THAT IF YOU ADD ANOTHER FOOT
TO THE LIVING SPACE IT REALLY
CREATES A LARGER SENSE SPACE.
AND PERHAPS A SMALLER
ENVIRONMENT I LEARNED AT ON
WORK WITH THE EXCESS RE
DWELLING UNITS IN THE HIGH I
KNOW A LOT OF CITY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN FOOT. UP A- MAN THEIR SIT
FAMILY HOMES CAN BE BUT BUT IF
YOU'RE ANTICIPATING PODIUM
PARKING FOR FIVE SPOTS THREE
LEVELS WITH YOU KNOW THREE
PEOPLE THREE UNITS. AN EXTRA
FOOT OR TWO FEET MADE THE
DIFFERENCE IN A VERY ENJOYABLE
LIVING SPACE IS ARE JUST SOME.
OBSERVATIONS IF THE AUTHOR
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT. SENATOR
WOULD YOU LIKE ME COMMENTED
THAT. GIVE ME I'M ON THE ON THE
FIRST- MATT- ISSUE I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT WE WILL TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT- AND- CLEARLY ONE
MAKE A SIMPLE SO THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND IN TERMS OF THE- THE
HEIGHTS IT'S NOT IT'S INTENDED
TO BE THREE STORIES AND THE
RESIDENTIAL AREAS FIVE STORIES.
AND A COMMERCIAL MIXED USE
AREAS- AND- SO THAT'S WHY I
MADE I BELIEVE IS THIRTY FIVE
AND FIFTY FIVE P. WITH THE IDEA
BEING THAT USUALLY WANT THE
GROUND FLOOR TO BE A LITTLE BIT.
HOLD TAL THE IDEA THE HOT FOR.
THE A TEN FOOT CEILINGS ON BUT
OUR HAPPY TO GO BACK TAKE A
LOOK THAT AS WELL GUY I JUST
THINK THERE'S THE STUFF IN
BETWEEN THE SHEET ROCK IN THE
OTHER AND THE SAME THING WITH
THE PODIUM PARKING IF THIS
PODIUM THING YOU KNOW YEAH A
LOT OF PEOPLE FOR SAFETY LIKE
TO HAVE A LITTLE BIT YOU KNOW
WHETHER IT'S TO. THREE PETER
FOUR FEET X. A BIG DIFFERENCE
FOR THAT SENSE OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD BUT THE OTHER MATT
MISTER VICE CHAIR ANOTHER ISSUE
I'D JUST LIKE TO RAISE IS I'M
OUT. I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT IF
CHURCHES BILL THESE THESE
HOUSING UNITS THEY'LL BE FULL
FLEDGED DISCRIMINATION BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT. IMPLICIT BIAS
IN SOME SORT OF LIMITATIONS.
THAT THESE CHURCHES WILL ALLOW
RENTERS OR PEOPLE TO COME ON
THE PROPERTY SO. I URGE THE
AUTHOR TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
FULL FAITH OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ANTI DISCRIMINATION LAWS ARE
EMBRACED ON THESE THESE PRIVATE
VENTURES BECAUSE- WELL HE JUST
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
EVERYBODY HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
LOOKED. ON THE SPOTS AND I
DON'T I'M NOT. POINTING FINGERS
OF EVERYBODY BEING ILL WILLED
BUT I JUST THINK THAT SOMETHING
HAPPENED- THAT. THAT WE MAY
FIND SAID ART INCLUDE IN THE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
VARIETY DIFFERENT REASONS.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU. SENATOR ALSO YES.
THANK YOU I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR INTRODUCING BILL
THAT IS REALLY FOCUSED ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING I THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT THE BIGGEST CRISIS
WITHIN THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT
WE ALL HAVE TO BE. COMMITTED TO
AND A ALL YOU'RE ALSO BELIEVE
THAT DOING THIS BY RIGHT
OBVIOUSLY IS INTENDED TO SPEED
THE SUBS SO THAT WE COULD MOVE
FORWARD AND DO THIS- IT IN A
WAY THAT ARE REALLY OF HAS
IMPACT I AM RAISING UPAN ISSUE
ABOUT IT'S AN ONGOING ISSUE I
THINK WITH THE REST OF THESE
BILLS AS WELL IS THAT THEY
SHOULDN'T BE A CONTRADICTION
WITH A SUPPORTING HIGH QUALITY
JOBS AND OF A TRAINED WORK FOR
A QUALITY TRAIN FOR SO. I
SUPPORT ABOUT THE- BUT TO
PLEASE INCLUDE LABOR ARE ON THE
BILL WHICH INCLUDE BOTH
PREVAILING WAGE AND A SKILLED
AND TRAINED QUALITY OF
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS Q. ANY OTHER
A- COMMENTS FROM OUR MEMBERS IS
THAT IT WAS THAT A QUESTION OR
IS THAT. A COMMON. DIRECTOR.
THANK RESPONSIBLE. YEAH THE
ONLY. WOULD YOU LIKE TO ADDRESS
THAT DOWN YES MISTER BY SERVE A
GOOD YEAH. SO I THANK YOU I
CENTER THERE ALSO CORRECT THAT
ISSUE- SO- I'VE BEEN IN- LIKE
THAT OFFICE FOR A DECADE NOW.
BOTH LOCAL AND NOW FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS IN THE SENATE- AND
DURING THAT TIME ENTIRE TIME
PERIOD- I'VE WORKED HAND IN
GLOVE WITH THE BUILDING TRADES.
LOCALLY AT THE STATE LEVEL. AS
A MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I WAS
CONSISTENTLY. PART OF EFFORTS
TO EXPAND ODJICK LABOR
AGREEMENTS I'VE BEEN SUPPORTIVE
OF HAVING A CITY WIDE LA. HI IN
SAN FRANCISCO. AND HERE IN THE
SENATE- I'VE BEEN CONSISTENTLY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES ON THE VARIOUS
PIECES OF HOUSING LEGISLATION
ARE CARRIED. OVER THE YEARS
STARTING WITH SB THIRTY FIVE
WHERE WE NEGOTIATED A VERY
SOLID A PREVAILING WAGE
UNSKILLED WORKFORCE- AGREEMENT-
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
I SENSE ON MY PRACTICE IS RIGHT
WHEN WE ARE PURSUING HOUSING
LEGISLATION WE ALERT THE TRADES
EARLY ON TO GET THEIR FEEDBACK
EARLY ON. AND WE WORK IT OUT.
USUALLY TO POSITION OF A
SUPPORT. SO I PUT MY MONEY
WHERE MY MOUTH IS WHEN IT COMES
TO WORKING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES I'M A STRONG BELIEVER IN
ENSURING THAT ARE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE NOT ONLY NOT.
POVERTY WAGES BETTER PAY WAGES.
WHERE THEY CAN BE PART OF THE
MIDDLE CLASS AND HAVE A SHOT AT
A FOURTEEN THE HOUSING THAT
THEY ARE. BUILDING THAT IS A
CORE VALUE FOR ME AND I AM
HAPPY OF COURSE TO WORK WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES. AND OTHER
UNIONS. ARE ON SB EIGHT NINETY
NINE- AND- MY ATTENTION WILL BE
TO CLOSE- BRING STAKEHOLDER
GROUP TOGETHER- THE TRADES AS
WELL AS- THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. COMMUNITY THIS IS NOT
A NEW ISSUE IN TERMS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THOSE TWO
COMMUNITIES AS I THINK PEOPLE
WHO FOLLOW THIS KNOWS SOME
AROUND TWENTY YEARS AGO. THERE
WAS LEGISLATION PASSED TO
REQUIRE THAT IF THERE'S ANY
STATE MONEY- AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT IT MUST PAY
PREVAILING WAGE THAT WAS A
FIGHT. WHEN I WAS PASSED WITH
OPEN WE WAS PASSED. SHIFTING
FROM NINE TO MANDATE A SKILLED
WORKFORCE AND- HUNDREDS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS A
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE. I'M NOT
COMMENTING ON NOT CRITICIZING
THAT CHANGED THE NOTING THAT IS
A SIGNIFICANT. CHANGE IN STATE
POLICY PERFECTLY LEGITIMATE
CONVERSATION TO HAVE AND I WILL
CONVENE. THAT ROUND TABLE TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION. I DO JUST
WANT TO KNOW POLITICS SINCE I
DO HAVE A HISTORY OF WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE TRADES
WE INTRODUCED THIS BILL. SB
NINE NINE IN THE MIDDLE OF
FEBRUARY HREE AND A HALF
MONTHS AGO. WE SENT IT TO THE
TRADES. THAT'S FEEDBACK DO NOT
GET ANY CRITICAL FEEDBACK ON
THE BILL AT ALL. AND THE NEXT I
HEARD FROM THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IS WHEN I GOT A PHONE
CALL YESTERDAY. ON MEMORIAL DAY
AT THREE O'CLOCK EIGHTEEN HOURS
HEARING- ASKING THAT I WOULD
IT'S CALLED WORKFORCE-
PROVISION IN THE BILL. IT WAS
COURSE TOO LATE. TO CONSIDER
SUCH A BIG CHANGE WITHOUT A
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS- WITH AND
RECEIVE THE OFFICIAL LETTERS.
WHEN TRADES LATE LAST NIGHT.
WELL PASSED THE COMMITTEE BUT
IT ONLINE AND FROM THE OTHER
UNIONS THIS MORNING FIFTEEN
MINUTES BEFORE THE HEARING
BEGAN. THE TEAMSTERS ARE NOT
SUBMITTED A LETTER- I WILL ALSO
SAY THAT OTHER THAN. MISTER
HUNTER FROM THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES NONE OF THESE OTHER
UNIONS HAVE REACH OUT TO ME.
EITHER BY LETTER. BEFORE THIS
MORNING OR BY PHONE. SO I JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE TRADE AS I
ALWAYS HAVE. ON IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE A COLLABORATIVE.
RESPECTFUL PROCESS WORKING WITH
ME AS AUTHOR AND WORKING WITH A
ROBUST AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY. AND I'M HOPING WE
CAN SET THE RESET BUTTON- AND
HAD A KIND OF COLLABORATIVE-
RESPECTFUL PROCESS AND I AM
COMMITTED TO DOING MASSIVE
THANK YOU SENATOR ROSS OF
RAISING THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
BOB WAS THERE ANY MORE SENATOR
ROBB. THE BILL OKAY SENATOR
MORE LOCK- GO AHEAD THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR. CENTER
WIENER. I'M I'M HAVING REAL
DIFFICULTY NOW- WITH- WONDERING
WHY A PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT
WOULD EVEN HAVE TO ENTER INTO
SOME OF THESE BY RIGHT
TRANSACTIONS WERE ALREADY
TREADING ON PRETTY SENSITIVE
TERRITORY- AYE AYE I WANT TO
SUPPRT THE BILL I PLAN ON
VOTING FOR TODAY BUT- I RESERVE
THE RIGHT THEN IT YOU'RE GONNA
MAKE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT MIGHT
THAT TO THE COSTS OF LEGITIMATE
ATTEMPTS TO BUILD EXTRA
HOUSING. I'M I MAY. CHANGED MY
MIND I JUST. WANTED LEAST THROW
THAT IN AS YOU. REVIEW THESE
ISSUES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER. OKAY. HE SENATOR
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I I'LL BE VERY
QUICK MESSAGE YOUR LOOK I THINK
THAT THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IN
SENATOR WIENER- WHILE- WE HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO WORK
THROUGH OUR DIFFERENCES ON
HOUSING HE HAS A HE'S HAD A
RECORD TO BETTER TACKLE THE
TOUGH IT IS AN ENGAGING ROBUST
CONVERSATION AND LET'S BE
HONEST THERE'S BEEN SOME WINS
AND LOSSES JUST LIKE WE ALL
HAVE. BUT HE HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT IN WORKING WITH THE
HARD WORKING MEN WOMEN OF THE
TRADES AND WANTED TO SAY HOW
GRATEFUL WE ARE- FOR THEM
CHIMING IN TO IN ADVANCING THE
CONCERNS THE ENDPOINT THOUGH
THE ENDPOINT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
WITH SENATOR WE- A- THAT. WE
END UP TOGETHER. I AM CONFIDENT
THAT THIS IS WHERE THIS
DISCUSSION WILL AIM IS WELL- BY
WORKING TOGETHER IN. THE
CHALLENGE I THINK THAT WE ALL
FACE RIGHT NOW IS IN THIS TIME
OF TRUNCATED SCHEDULES DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC. AND ARE
LEGISLATIVE DEADLINES. THIS
BILL WILL ONLY BE HEARD IN ONE
POLICY COMMITTEE BUT DO TRUST
CENTER WINNER OF ADVANCING THAT
ROBUST INPUT PROCESS THAT WILL
BE HAPPY WITH STAKEHOLDERS THAT
WILL BE A IT WOULD BE DIRECTLY
WORKING WITH HIM. IN YEAH YOU
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I THINK THE IMPORTANT
PART ABOUT THIS IS THAT AS-
WINNER IS ALWAYS PERSON DOES
WORK- IN ADVANCE IN THOSE
SOLUTIONS IN A COLLABORATIVE
MANNER SO. THAT WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS KNOWING THAT
THERE WILL NEED TO BE
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION HERE IN
THE WEEKS TO COME IN THANK YOU
CENTER WITH. OKAY SENATOR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIR COLLEAGUES I
WANT A THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FEEDBACK- THERE ARE OF COURSE
GOING TO BE A LOT OF OPINIONS
ON THIS BILL ONLY BECAUSE IT'S
AN IMPACTFUL BILL THIS BILL
WILL HELP FACILITATE A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF NEW
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OVER TIME
IT'S AN IMPORTANT BILL- YES WE
HAVE WORK TO DO AND I'M
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION ON SB EIGHT
NINETY NINE- THAT WAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR ROCK-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL EIGHT
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR WINNER
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
WINNER. BY WIENER AYE MORALE
HIGH MORALE I CABALLERO HI ZERO
DORADO HI DORADO I MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE MORE LOOK. MORE LIKE A
ROCK. ROTH AYE SKINNER AYE
SKINNER AYE NUMBER. WITH CASKEY
HI WITH HEALTHCARE I NINE VOTES.
NINE EYES AND WILL HOLD THAT
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL FOR-
SOME OF OUR OTHER SENATORS WILL
BE HERE IN A WHILE. WOULD YOU.
SENATOR WIENER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT SB NINE OH TWO I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR TALK POLITICS SENATE BILL
NINE OH TWO IS A YOUR LOCAL
CONTROL BILL I IN FACT DEAD HI
INCREASES LOCAL CONTROL BY
ALLOWING CITIES-TO ACCELERATE.
THERE'S ONLY PROCESS DISPLAYED-
THE STATE LAW THAT CAN OFTEN
MAKE THAT PROCESS TAKES YEARS
OR EVEN A DECADE SB NINE OH TO
CREATE A POWERFUL NEW TOOL THAT
CITIES CAN CHOOSE TO USE OR
CHOOSE NOT TO YOU'RE- I THIRTY
BASIC HOUSING DENSE. AND THIS
WAY. THE BILL LIMITS NEW TOOL
THE HOUSING UP TO TEN UNITS.
LOCATED IN URBAN INFILL. FOR A
JOB RICHARD TRANSIT RICH AREA
IN ORDER TO AVOID SPRAWL. ARE
THE BILL IS A PART OF THE
SENATE HOUSING PACKAGE AND I
WANT TO THANK HER FOR TEN
CENTER ATKINS WHO WAS A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
UNDER CURRENT LAW WHEN THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT INITIATES
REZONING I CITY DECIDES THEY
WANT TO HAVE MORE DENSITY IN A
PARTICULAR PART OF THEIR CITY-
THE REZONING MUST GO THROUGH
EXTENSIVE SEQUEL REVIEW. AND
CAN IS VULNERABLE TO APPEALS
SERIAL LAWSUITS EVEN IF THE UP
SEVENTY IS EXCLUSIVELY FOCUSED
ON MILE DENSITY INCREASES. AND
URBAN INFILL JOB IN TRANSIT
RICH COMMUNITIES. AS A RESULT
CITIES THAT WANT TO DO THE
RIGHT THING THAT WANT TO DO
WHAT WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO
WHICH IS HIS OWN FOR MORE
HOUSING. CAN FACE A LENGTHY CAN
BE AS MUCH AS FIVE OR TEN
YEARS. AND VERY EXPENSIVE
PROCESS- IN ORDER TO DO WHAT
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO DO AND
THIS CREATES A MAJOR
DISINCENTIVE FOR CITIES. TO
RESULT AND WITH THE CHANGES TO
THE REASON A HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT- DUE TO SB EIGHT TWO
EIGHT WAS A AUTHORED A FEW
YEARS AGO WHICH IS LEADING TO
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES AND
CITIES HOUSING GOALS THEY WILL
NEED TO ENGAGE IN REZONING TO
MEET THOSE GOALS WE SHOULD MAKE
IT. EASIER FOR THE- ON SB NINE
OF TWO CHANGES THE STATE OF
AFFAIRS. BY THE CLARION THAT
THE DECISION TO ADOPT. AN UPS
ONING. IF IT IS AN INFILL
TRANSIT OR JOB AREA NOT SPRAWL.
AND IF IT'S UP TO TEN UNITS- IS
NOT A PROJECT IN THE SEQUEL. AS
LONG AS IT MADE ME SEE
SUSTAINABILITY. CRITERIA
INDIVIDUAL DEVELOPMENTS
CONSISTENT WITH THESE PLANS.
WILL REQUIRE WILL HAVE TO MEET
ALL LOCAL REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE
DESIGN REVIEW IMPACT FEES- THEY
CAN BE SUCH AS THE PLANNING
COMMISSION DISCRETIONARY REVIEW
BY THE CITY THEY ALSO- WILL BE
SUBJECT TO WHATEVER HEIGHT
LIMIT- THE CITY SETS SERVICES
LOCAL CONTROL. THE BILL HAS
SIGNIFICANT POTENTIAL TO
EMPOWER LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
PURSUE MORE EQUITABLE OF
SURNAMES FOR SMALL SCALE. AND
MEDIUM DENSITY CONSTRUCTION. IN
SYSTEM WITH FAIR HOUSING LAWS.
IN ADDITION BY FOCUSING ON THE
SMALLER PROJECTS AS UNITED TO
PROMOTE ITS NEW HOMEOWNERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FIRST TIME
BUYERS AS WELL AS PROMOTING
NATURALLY INEXPENSIVE. WOOD
FRAME CONSTRUCTION CONSISTING
WITNESSES MISSING MIDDLE NEEDS
IN OUR NEIGHBORHOODS. REGARDING
THE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL- AND
I DON'T SCORE SPEAK FOR ANY
OPPONENTS THIS BILL WAS AMENDED
ON THE SAME DAY THAT THE
OPPOSITION LETTER DEADLINE WAS-
AND UNTIL LAST WEDNESDAY IN
ADDITION TO THOSE VOLUNTARY
STREAMLINED OF ZONING ALSO
CONTAINED A REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOWED DUPLEX TRI PLEX. FOR
PARKS AND LOOKING AT THE
OPPOSITION LETTERS THAT APPEARS
TO BE THE FOCUS THE REQUIREMENT
THE CITY'S ALLOWED DUPLEX
TRIPLEX FOUR BUCKS AND OF
COURSE WHEN THEY CENTERS
OPPOSITION THEY HAVEN'T SEEN
OUR AMENDMENTS THAT REMOVE THAT
FROM THE BILL ENTIRELY AND THE
REASON WE REMOVED IT. BECAUSE
IS IN SB A TWENTY BY THE PRO
TEM. THAT INCLUDE THE STATE
WIDE DUPLEX AND LOTS SPLIT
REQUIREMENTS SO UP TO FOUR
UNITS FOR PARCEL. AND SO THAT.
TOOK CARE OF THAT AREA AND WE
DIDN'T WAN TO DUPLICATE OR
HAVE ANY KIND OF INCONSISTENT-
APPROACH TO REMOVE IT FROM OUR
BILL AND I SIGNED ON AS A JOINT
AUTHORED. TO THE PROTONS BILL-
AND SO I KNOW THAT SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AND MYBE THE BOOK
OF THE OPPOSITION HAS REALLY
BEEN FOCUSING. ON A PROVISION
THAT WAS REMOVED ON THE SAME
DAY THAT THE OPPOSITION LETTERS
WERE DO- AGAIN NOT SPEAKING FOR
THE OPPOSITION WITH THAT IS AT
LEAST MY- PERCEPTION THIS IS
NOW A BILL THAT GIVES A
VOLUNTARY. POWER NEW TOOL FOR
CITIES TO BE ABLE TO CHOOSE TO
UPS ON A STREAMLINED AND LESS
EXPENSIVE WAY. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR ON A VOTE TESTIFYING
TODAY ARE. ARE SPONSOR IS
RESTING ON ITS TO HOLLY OFFER
MANY FROM HABITAT FOR HUMANITY.
AND THE RESTAURANT TODAY FROM
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. YES AN
ADJUSTER MINOR THEY'LL BE A
TOTAL THREE MINUTES TO-
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. SO LET'S BEGIN
IN THE GALLERY. BIRTH OKAY TO
KEY WITNESSES ARE ON THE PHONE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO. HOLLY DAY HAS
ZEUS FIGHT IT. OR LUIS MANTE.
HOW TO WRITE YOUR CAN YOU HEAR
ME THIS IS LOUIS MANTECH. WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU YES. OKAY HELLO
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY- MY
NAME IS LOUIS BROWN SAY I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BEACH- WE ORGANIZE
FOR AN ADVOCATE FOR QUALITY IN
THE STATE AND LOCAL LEVELS THAT
WOULD HELP CALIFORNIA RESOLVE
IT HISTORY HOUSING AND HOUSING
CRISIS THAT HAS RESULTED FROM
UNDER BUILDING. I THINK CENTER
WIENER DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
COVERING THE DETAILS OF THE
BILL. SO I'M JUST GOING TO
FOCUS ON- WHY WE'RE SUPPORTING
IT- THIS BILL CALLED THE REAL
PROBLEM THAT ARE LOCAL ALLIES
AROUND THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND FLAGGED
FOR US- JURISDICTIONS ARE
CAUGHT. BETWEEN A ROCK AND A
HARD PLACE AND NEEDING TO
COMPLY WITH THE BEING REGIONAL
HOUSING NEEDS ALLOCATION- AND
POTENTIALLY FACING A LAWSUIT
FROM A NEW MEET IN THEIR AREA
FOR DOING SO. I WE THINK THAT
AS NINE OH TWO IT'S GONNA.
REALLY HELP CALIFORNIA PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED HOUSING. AND IF YOU
KNOW THE NINETEEN HAS RENDERED
THE HOUSING CRISIS IN QUITE
PAINFUL CLARITY FOR EVERYONE IN
THE STATE. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WORK AT THAT
HOMEBUILDING WILL DROP 21% THIS
YEAR I 21% BELOW A NUMBER THAT
WOULD. HOW OCTOBER NINETEEN IS
ALSO THE POTENTIALLY REDUCE
LOCAL RENT MEETING THAT AT ALL
THE MORE IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
THE JURISDICTION THEIR PLANS
FOR COMBINED WITH THE BUT THE
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW FOR LISTING
COSTLY LAWSUITS FOR THE MORE.
RECENT RESEARCH FROM THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF HOME
BUILDERS FIND THE BUILDING A
THOUSAND POUNDS IN CREATE TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FULL TIME
JOBS. AND GENERATE ALMOST A
HUNDRED AND ELEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TAXES AND FEES FOR
ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT.
SUPPORT LIKE POLICE
FIREFIGHTERS AND SCHOOLS ARE
SOMETHING ALL THE MORE
IMPORTANT- AS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE FACING NOT THE BUDGET
SHORTFALLS IF YOU'RE ALL WHERE.
THANK YOU FOR ALL THESE REASONS
ARE REALLY PLEASED TO BE HERE
TODAY TO ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT
AFTER FOR SB OKAY THANK YOU.
OUR NEXT- HOLLY DAY HIS HIS
PLEASE. HI MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC
FOR MANY DATA FROM BEHALF THE
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY CALIFORNIA
AND ITS FORTY AFFILIATE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THE
THIRD. FOUR FOUR THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED FAMILIES OVER THE PAST
TEN YEARS 67% WHO ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR ARE. BEING 30% 80% OF THE
AREA MEDIAN AND THEN. PARTNER
RETENTION. YOUNG PURCHASED
RESTRICTED AFFORDABLE HOME. IN
TIMES LIKE THESE. THE
CALIFORNIA STATE HOME ORDER.
IT'S EVEN MORE IMPORTANT THAN
EVER THAT WE HAVE DECENT HOME
FOR PEOPLE TO STAY IN AND IT'S
JUST UNCLEAR HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO BE BEFORE. THE NEW
NORMAL AND HOW LONG IT'S GOING
TO LAST WE HAVE CHILDREN. THAT
ARE NOW FORCED TO LEARN FROM
HOME INSTEAD OF IN THE
CLASSROOM AND PARENTS WHO ARE
WORKING AT HOME. AND WITH OR
WITHOUT A JOB ENTIRELY. WE OWE
IT TO OUR COMMUNITY TO CREATE
MORE HOMES FOR THE FAMILY. AND
BUILD MORE AFFORDABLE UNITS BY
DIVINE. IN ORDER TO THAT.
REALLY CREATIVE SOLUTIONS
INCENTIVIZE AND REMOVE BARRIERS
FOR PRODUCING MORE SMALLER
HOUSING UNITS. THAT ARE MORE
AFFORDABLE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
AGAIN I MEAN THAT'S- BY DESIGN
AFTER SMALLER AN ENTRY LEVEL IT
WILL BE CHEAPER FOR US TO BUILD.
AND THE MULTIPLE LAYERS OF THE
COURT REVIEW THROUGH THIS
PROCESS. LOCAL CARRIERS FOR
THOSE CITIES THAT ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO THE RIGHT
THING THE DRAFT THE HOUSING
CRISIS IN THE REGION. BY TRYING
TO PERMIT AND PLAN FOR THE
SMALLER UNIT. SINGLE FAMILY
DETACHED FROM OR EVEN A VISION
OF THE- THANK YOU. THANK YOU
HOLLY HERE NOW BUILDING. MULTI
FAMILY UNITS THAT A TEN UNITS
ARE LAST. ENCOUNTER BANKRUPT OR
HOME WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THEMSELVES THANK YOU. OKAY ANY-
WITNESSES IN THE GALLERY. IN
AGAIN JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE PLACE. EVER CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. ANY
OTHER IN A GALLERY IF NOT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO
OH FOR ALL WHO WISH TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE I'LL KILL.
ZERO OKAY NOW WILL MOVE ON TO-
OUR WITNESS WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE- TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
AND AGAIN I JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU TO PLEASE. YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION A POSITION ON THE
BILL ONLY. MODERATOR HI THERE.
FOR THAT PART PRESS ONE ZERO
AND WE WILL BEGIN WITH LINE
FIFTY SEVEN. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE NONPROFIT. HELP I DO REAL
DOUBLE OF THE NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT WE WILL THAT
ONLINE NINETY EIGHT. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME ADDRESS THE
LACK OF THE A CRANK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE THAT THE REPEAT
COALITION WHICH INCLUDES THE
CANAL AT HOME THE SAN FRANCISCO
FOUNDATION CAN GIVE PARTNERS
AND SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. WILL THAT A LINE
NINETEENTH AT. NINE ZERO. THIS
IS- BOB NAY- REPRESENTING FEELS
THAT IN COMPANY AN ORANGE
COUNTY MAYES BUSINESS WHICH IS
A STRONG YOU CAN BE SUPPORTER
THEY WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE OH TWO. NEXT WE'LL
ABOUT ONLINE NINETY NINE. THIS
IS GREG HERDER WERE CARPENTERS
HEATERS ON BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER
ELECTRIC WORK AMERICA IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. LOOK AT
ONLINE FIFTY SIX. IF THE FAN ON
BEHALF OF BRIDGE HOUSING AND
SUPPORT. NEXT SO THAT ONLINE
SEVENTY FIVE. CORD ON BEHALF OF
BAY AREA HOUSING HAD THE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. NEXT CALL
THAT A LINE NINETY SEVEN. GOOD
MORNING SENATOR DOLLAR STORES
WITH STRATEGY THREE SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF UP FOR GROWTH ACTION
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY NINE.
THIS IS ABBY TANNING WITH THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL CALLING IN
SUPPORT. NEXT DEADLINE SIXTEEN.
GOOD MORNING BILL BILL FOR ARE
YOU FACEBOOK IN SUPPORT. NEXT
DEADLINE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION YEAH
SUPPORT. NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTY
FIVE. IN A GALLAGHER FOR THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
NINE FORTY THREE. INSTRUCTION
FROM THE SILICON VALLEY
LEADERSHIP GROUP IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE FIFTY
FIVE. OUT OF MIND FIFTY FIVE GO
AHEAD. WHAT ARE THE NEXT MINUTE
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD MORNING
BATTLE BILLION THIS ON BEHALF
OF THE GREEN LINE INSTITUTE IN
SUPPORT. NEXT HEADLINE EIGHTY
ONE. FOR GO AHEAD NINE EIGHTY
ONE. OKAY THE NEXT LINE UP ONE
HUNDRED AND ONE. I THANK YOU
MISTER I'M LOOKING AT DAVID AND
ALL THE WHILE THE TALK SHOW A
NONPROFIT HOUSING PROVIDER NOW
THE CITY GROUP BERMAN WHICH
WIENER WE HAVE REMOVED OR
OPPOSITION WITH THE LATEST ON
THEM AND CAN SUMMON. MEETING
ONE ON EACH ON THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. BOTTOM LINE. ONE
OH FIVE. HI THIS IS MEGHAN ABLE
WITH A COOPERATIVE IN SUPPORT.
AND IF THERE IS ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE
TIME. BUT ONLINE FIFTY SEVEN.
HI THERE THIS IS ENTERING ITS
STRUCTURE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. AND THERE IS NO ONE
OUT THANK YOU. OKAY AFTER NO
MORE WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT BY
WE WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME
PROCESS IN HERE FROM ANY IN
OPPOSITION. WE CAN BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN A GALLERY.
WHAT'S. ARE THERE ANY WRITTEN
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO OH FOR
ALL WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SENATE BILL. NINE
ZERO TWO. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE PROMPTED INITIALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE ALL TO WE
WILL BEGIN. AND PRESS ONE ZERO
IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION WE
WILL BEGIN WITH LINE NINETY
FIVE. GUIDELINE NINETY FIVE.
SORRY THIS IS A MAJOR THE
MARKETPLACES ASIAN I AM AND I
CAN GET IN THE QUEUE SO. THIS
ONE TO MAKE SURE I GOT IN THERE.
NEXT WE WILL GO TO LINE NINETY
THREE. HI DAVID KING CALLING ON
BEHALF OF A BETTER WAY FOR
HELPING CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT DEADLINE
EIGHTY ONE. GOOD MORNING MIKE
BONTA GONNA BE HALF THE CALPERS
A CESSATION MCCORKLE WORKERS%
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
TRADES COUNCIL BUSTER STATE
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS WE
ARE PROPOSAL LET'S BUILD
AMENDED TO INCLUDE LABOR
PROTECTIONS THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE NINETEEN. ALLEN LINE
NINETEEN ONE NINE. OVER THE
NEXT LINE ON THAT ONE TO. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MATT CRAVEN COUNTY AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE HERE TODAY
IN LATE OPPOSITION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. THANK LINE NINETY ONE.
NUMBER THIS IS NOT A PROBLEM BE
AFTER THE TEAMSTERS BEGAN AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AND WE
WOULD- ECHO THAT SENTIMENT AT
THE UNION. GREAT THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE NINETY SIX. YES
THIS IS MIKE WELL REPRESENTING
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES IN
WERE ALIGNED WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE WILL GO TO LINE NINETEEN. GO
AHEAD NINETEEN ARE YOU ON MUTE.
IT IS THIS FOR OUR JOURNEY YEAH
IT WILL BE VERY. I GOT ARE YOU
IN OPPOSITION. I AM I A NOBODY
CAN ONE TO GIVE ME A NUMBER SO
I DIDN'T KNOW THAT THAT WAS MY
FAULT. OKAY YET. SO I GOT THAT
RIGHT HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL OF RESPECT WHAT
POSITION AS WELL WE DO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR- ON THIS BILL AND THE
PREVIOUS BELT- YOU THINK YOUR
GROSS COMMENTS. HOUSTON
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL FOR
MANY REASONS STATED IN MY
EARLIER COMMENT ON THE PREVIOUS
BILL THANK. THERE'S NO ONE OUT
IN THE QUEUE. OKAY IF THERE ARE
NO MORE WITNESSES IN THE QUEUE-
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR WHO
WAS IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THIS
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
MEMBERS ANY. SENATOR DORADO
PLACE YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- I WANT TO AGAIN APPLY
THE AUTHOR FOR LOOKING FOR HOW
WE CAN CREATE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INCREASE IN INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
I BELIEVE THAT YOU KNOW FIRST
OF ALL THIS IS A STREAMLINING
PROCESS BILL. UP BUT WE'RE ALSO
LEGISLATIVELY GOING THROUGH A
STREAMLINING PROCESS I MEAN
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT NO ONE
OF US HAVE VERY EXPERIENCED I
THINK IT'S REALLY JOLTED US
INTO HOW DO WE ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND- I THINK WE SHOULD.
EXPECT THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
GETTING A LOT OF LAST MINUTE
CONVERSATION SO I JUST I JUST
WANT TO REMIND US ALL OF THAT-
SO I WONDER REYES- A THREE
ISSUES- AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN
ESTABLISH THEM. AS SOME GOOD
FRIENDS OF MINE CALL IT HARD
RAILS OF ONE IS. TO PREVENT
BUILDING HOUSING IN OVERCROWDED
AREAS- TO IS TO PREVENT AND-
PROTECT ROSE FROM THIS BECOMING
SHORT TERM RENTALS AND OR
HOTELS AND THREE. TO ENSURE AS
I SAID EARLIER AND THE PREVIOUS
BILL- THE LABOR STANDARDS SO I
WANT TO BRING TO EVERYONE'S
ATTENTION OF THE PROBLEM OF
OVERCROWDING AND SEVERE
OVERCROWDING- IT IS AN ISSUE IN
MANY CITIES ACROSS THE STATE
WHILE THERE ARE AREAS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT HAVE. ZERO
OVERCROWDING OF FOR EXAMPLE IN
MY DISTRICT APPROXIMATELY 50%
OF THE CENSUS TRACKS AND TUNED
IN JUST TO NEIGHBORHOODS IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS AND WESLEY HAVE
OVERCROWDED- HOUSEHOLDS YOU SEE
DID AN OVERCROWDING- STUDY.
OVERCROWDING MEANS MORE THAN
ONE PERSON PER ONE ROOM IN THE
IN THE UNIT MORE THAN ONE
PERSON PER PER ROOM SO MAD CHEN
50% OF THE CENSUS TRACKS IN ONE
NEIGHBORHOOD- I. I AM VERY
CONCERNED THAT A BY RIGHT
PROCESS WILL BE USED IN THESE
OVER CROWDED AREAS AND IT WILL
WORSEN EXISTING HOUSING AND
FRANKLY WHAT COMES FROM
OVERCROWDING ARE HEALTH ISSUES
AND SAFETY CONCERNS- HEALTH
ISSUES THAT ARE PERMANENT. FOR
CHILDREN GROWING UP IN
OVERCROWDED CROWDED AREAS AW IT
HAS A BIG IMPACT ON THEIR
LEARNING- THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ALREADY TRACKS OVERCROWDING AND
WE CAN USE THAT DATA TO ENSURE
THAT HOUSING THE BUILD IS BUILT
IN AREAS WITH SUFFICIENT SPACE.
AS I MENTIONED JUST TO
NEIGHBORHOODS IN MY DISTRICT
BUT I ALSO HAVE NEIGHBORHOODS
LIKE CLOSE FAMILIES SWITCHES
ZERO EIGHT PERCENT- IN OTHER
PARTS OF LOS ANGELES WE HAVE
SOUTH LA 3250% OVERCROWDING BUT
WE HAVE SHERMAN OAKS WITH ZERO
TO FIVE PERCENT. AND BEL AIR
WITH 0% SO THERE ARE. THE
BIGGEST CONCERN IS THOSE AREAS
THAT ARE OVERCROWDED AND THE
IMPACT THAT IT WILL HAVE ON
THEM. THE SECOND ONE IS- THAT
AS WE STREAMLINED HOUSING
UNITS. I AM. THAT WE MAKE SURE
THAT IS NOT GOING TO CREATE A
SHORT TERM RENTALS OR HAVE
HOTELS SKEWS ME. WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
BECOME AN OPPORTUNITY FOR NEW
SHORT TERM RENTAL UNITS THAT'S
NOT THE KIND OF HOUSING THAT WE
SHOULD BE TALKING ABOUT. AND
AGAIN I JUST WANNA- ECKEL- THE
CONCERNS OVER THE LABOR
STANDARDS- SO AGAIN- I HOPE
THAT WE CAN BRING EVERYONE I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS WILL MEET AT AND-
AND FIGURE OUT SOLUTIONS TO
THOSE ISSUES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. MOVE THE BILL. I CENTER
I KASKI THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR- THROUGH THE VICE CHAIR
TO THE AUTHOR I'M WONDERING
THESE MAPS THAT YOU WE
ANTICIPATE FROM THE BILL FOR
THE TRANSIT RICH AREAS AND THE
JOBS RICH AREAS WHY THOSE ARE
NOT WITH THE AGENCY THAT DEALS
WITH TRANSPORTATION- DEALS WITH
JOBS PURCHASE VERSUS ATD WHICH
HAS A LOT. ON THEIR PLATE YEAH.
MISTER VICE CHAIR OF THE AUTHOR
COULD ANSWER. SENATOR WIENER
PLAYTIME SO ON THE BIG PICTURE-
EIGHT CITY IS UNDERSTAFFED.
THEY'VE GONE THROUGH A MAJOR
MANAGEMENT TRANSITION THE
DIRECTOR RULES BEACON METCALF
FOR FISHING SIX MONTHS NOW BEEN
FILLED- AND I THINK ANYONE WHO
WORKS IN THE HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION ADVOCACY WORLD.
KNOWS THAT ISSUE THE NEEDS
SUPPORT MY VIEW IS WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE WERE BOLSTERING THE
AGENCIES THAT ARE CONTRARY TO
WHAT. JOB BUT GREAT PEOPLE
DOING GREAT WORK THERE BUT
THERE AREN'T ENOUGH PEOPLE KNOW
TOO MANY VACANCIES. SO I ALSO
OF THE VIEW THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
A CABINET LEVEL HOUSING AGENCY
WITH THE SECRETARY OF HOUSING
AND REPORTING DIRECTLY TO THE
GOVERNOR THAT'S A WHOLE OTHER
ISSUE- IN TERMS OF DOING THESE
MAPS. EIGHT CITY ALREADY
OVERSEAS MAPPING BECAUSE
MAPPING HAS TO HAPPEN IN
VARIOUS RELY HOUSING. PROGRAMS
AROUND WHAT WE CALL HIGH
OPPORTUNITY. AREAS WHICH IS WE
DO WITH THE SAME AS AS JOB
RECALL JOB WHICH WAS WAY HIGH
PATERNITY. SO THEY ALREADY. FOR
BERKELEY WHO DO THIS MAPPING. I
SAW THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
ALREADY THERE TO DO THE
MAPPINGS IT'S NOT DONE IN HOUSE
AT THE CITY VERY THE CONTRACT
OUT TO DO IT. AND SO I THINK
THEY WILL BE ABLE TO DO THIS
SEAMLESSLY. BUT YOU DO NEED TO
STEP IT UP BECAUSE IT TOO MANY
VACANCIES. SO I TOTALLY THAT
THIS IS TOTALLY VOLUNTARILY
VOLUNTARY FOR ANY CITY THAT
WANTS TO DO IT SO I GET THAT
PART OF IT BUT WITH THAT SAID
THIS IS A HUGE SEQUEL EXEMPTION
THEIR CREATION OF A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR TEN UNITS ON A
PARCEL NOT TEN UNITS ON AN ACRE
TEN UNITS ON A PARCEL IS THERE
ANYTHING IN THIS BILL THAT
PROHIBITS SOMEBODY FROM.
COLLECTING WERE ASSEMBLING OVER
A SEVERAL PARCELS IN ORDER TO
DEVELOP CREATED DEVELOPMENT
THAT MAY HAVE FOR PARCELS ON IT
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE ONE LOCKED.
THE VICE SENATOR WINNER YES IT
IS THE CITY WILL HAVE EVERY OF.
WHEN THEY THIS THREE TO. AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO TENURE
SO CAN SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO TO
PART HERE OR FOUR PLUS. FOR SIX
BUCKS HERE IN CLOCKS THERE
THREE CAN GO ANYWAY FROM TWO
TEN I DON'T HAVE TO GO ALL THE
WAY TO THEY ALSO ON DON'T
DIDN'T HERE. WHAT IN ANY WAY
THAT TO ALLOW A LOT MORE SO
FROM IS HASN'T. TO THE TERM
WHETHER TO MURDER. LAW FIVE
WHETHER IT'S A- USE OR WHATEVER
IS THAT WILL REMAIN IN PLACE
AND CITY. OKAY TO HAVE POWER.
TO TREAT ALL OF THESE. PROJECTS
UNDER NORMAL APPROVAL RULES HI
SO WE'RE NOT IN ANYWAY TAKING
AWAY CITIES POWERS AROUND LOT
MERGERS A LOT SPLIT SERVER OR
HELLO THROUGH PROJECTS BUT
SIMPLY ALLOWING THEM IF THEY
CHOOSE TO READ OWN IN A MORE
STREAMLINED WAY THAT WE'RE NOT
MANDATING WHAT THEY DO WITH THE
INDIVIDUAL PRIOR OCCASIONS. SO
THIS IS SAID IN. NONE THE LESS
ON A C. WORK I SEE THE- TO THE
EIGHTY YOU BILL MADE ME SO.
BECAUSE TYPICALLY WHAT DID IN A
SIX EIGHT WAS TO. PEOPLE
BOOTLEG YOU INTO THEIR GO. N. I
THE BILL THE TERM TO SAY THE
OKAY GOING TO MAKE THE THINGS
LESS AND SOMETIMES PEOPLE
BOOTLEG A UNIT INTO THEIR BACK
OUR SO HE JUST WELL IF YOU IF
YOU CAN BOOTLEG IT THEIR GARAGE
INTO THE INTO BACKING. IT'S
LEGAL YOU COULD HAVE TO SO YOU
DO GET SOME TENSE. BUT AS ON
WITH THAT BUT THE PERCEPTION
WAS THAT ARE INVISIBLE NOW IN
THE- MY CONCERN IS THAT
CREATING THE SICK. INFANTS AT
PEACE. WELL MEANING CITY TO A-
LOSE ON HUMILITY FACT THAT
ACTIVITY WILL HAVE YOU KNOW OF
THE THINGS THIS WITH THE IS IT
ALLOWS FOR THE STATE. TO COME
IN AND COME SO IF YOU HAVE MADE
ONE FOUR PLEX MAY ONE TWO PLEX
ONE AT SIX PLUS IS YOUR
REMOVING OR BILL REMOVE THAT
THAT'S PART. IN AN COURSE OF
AND ADAPTIVE. SIX RE. YEAH
SINCE ACTUAL SIZE MISTER VICE
CHAIR THE VOTE THAT CAN ANSWER.
US SENATOR WE IF YOU LIKE AND A
RESPECTFUL TO MIKE COLLEAGUES
IN FREMONT AYE AYE AGREE WITH
THAT CAR IS A- FIRST OF ALL
THIS E HAVE. IF A IN A LIKE
CITY TO. WANTS THAT TO HAPPEN.
WHAT CITY HALL THERE IS ARIANNA.
OWNING OR- THAT WILL BE A
PUBLIC PROCESS. ARE WHERE THE
PA IS ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
ADDITION A FIVE FOR EACH AND-
PROJECT. DEPEND ON HOW THE
CITY'S. ITS ROLE. LOCALLY
AROUND APPROVE. EACH CAN BE. TO
THE USE SICK WHAT. SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE AN ATTORNEY'S
REMEMBER OF THE PUBLIC TO GET
YOU TO PARTICIPATE. I AN ANSWER
I AGREE. THIS PATIENT DOES DO I
ALL WELL WHEN I WHAT I WILL SAY
IS THAT YOU KNOW I AS I NOR
THIRD TO DECLARE A OF TIMES THE
WORK THAT I DO ON HOUSING
SOMETIME. USED REDUCING THE
GOING TO IN THE CITY THEY DON'T
TAKE AWAY. HOGAN THIS IS A AND
WHAT THEY ALSO SAY AND
INSTANCES NEEDING FUNDING
REFORM HOUSING I AGREE WITH ON
THEY ALSO SAY YOU WANT TO
HOUSING BUT YOU MAKE A TOO HARD
US TO YOU DO THAT CAN YOU
PLEASE GIVE US SOME. IT EASIER
NOT TO THEY'VE DONE IS GIVES
THEM CLOSE TO AND WHAT COULD
AND WHAT. YEAH WELL. DO YOU
WHAT. DO NEED TO YEAR. PROVIDE
I GET WE'RE A BRIEF OKAY. OUR
MILK THE CAN COME ON THAT. IF I
CAN IT IT APPROPRIATE FOR THE
TO LAY WITH THE- OF A SORT HIS
OWN ORDINANCE YEAH THIS
ORDINANCE HAVE FULL HEARING
THAT MAY NOT BE FULLY VETTED
AND WHO'S IN. ARE NOT COMMITTED
AND ALTERNATIVES CAN BECAUSE
GET THE SERVICE. I'M PROUD. ONE
TOLL YOU JUST SAY OKAY WE'RE
GONNA THE ZONING AND IT YOU
WE'VE ALL HAD SOME LOCAL.
EXPERTS IN IS JUST YOU KNOW THE
SONY ORDINANCE OF RAP WILL PAY
THAT THAT AND YOU KEEP SEE IT
SO THAT. AYE AYE AYE A- I. AM
NOT HAVING HER COME JUST IN
PROP BREATHING OR THE SIX
CHALLENGE ARE GOING TO. I'M I'M
PREPARED TO VOTE FOR THE BILL
TODAY. A MISTER CHAIR AND HELP
GET OUT OF THE CAN BUT I DO
WANT TO RE THESE. SAID THIS IS
NOT JUST A LITTLE A FOR THIS IS
A BIG THING. BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS ORDER ALTERNATE THE PEOPLE
OTHER THAN TO GO TO THE SUIT
THIS PUBLIC PART. PER SO I HOPE
THAT OTHER. THIS SIR CAN. MAY
ARE. YES I'M AND SENATOR ALLEN
AND I CHAIR OF THE BAR
ACCORDING TO TALK A REGULAR
ABOUT HOUSING AND WILL CONTINUE
DO SO AND I WOULD NEVER EVER TO
DO ANYTHING TO GIVE YOU A HEART
ATTACK SO LIKE HEALTH CARE SO
WILL MAKE WHEN THEY SURE NEVER
TO DO. OKAY THANK YOU. SENATOR
MORLOCK THANK YOU MISTER BY
WIENER LAST MONTHS THE GENERAL
IS TAKEN AT ONE OF EIGHTY THE
TURN ON DENSE THANKS TO THE
COVERED. PANDEMIC SO WHAT WHAT
ARE WE ABOUT DENSITY RBC NEW
CITY IS BEEN IMPACTED SO
FRANCIS BECAUSE BEEN IMPAIR.
LAWS ANGELES HAS BEEN IMPACTED
SO WHEN SOMEONE SAYS ADDING TEN
UNITS TO A PARCEL VERSUS TEN
UNITS TO AN ACRE OR SOMETHING
THAT. YOUR TO QUANTIFY. WHERE
WERE WE LOOKING IN THE FUTURE
AS TO WHAT IS AN APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OF UNITS ON AN ACRE. I
SENATOR WIENER WHICH I CANCER
THAT I YES I WOULD VERY MUCH
LOVE TO ANSWER QUESTION THE
SERVER YOUR THANK YOU CENTER
MORE LAW THIS WILL TIE INTO ONE
OF THE- CONTACT CENTER TO ROSS
SO RAISES WHILE TERMS A CREDIT.
RIGHT IT'S A REAL REALLY ARE.
AT THE STATE WEST. BETWEEN
CROWDING WITH HOME CROWDING
WITH AN HOMES. THIRD DENSITY
WITH NO WHEN YOU HAVE YOUR OF
TO PEOPLE LIVE IN A HOUSE UNIT
OR PEOPLE. VERSUS DENSITY OF
HOW UNITS THE A NUMBER HOME.
AND WE LOOK AT WHAT A RE OF CAN.
IT'S NOT YOU KNOW I LIVE IN A
THIRTY NINE BUILDING. THAT AND
THE BY MYSELF THERE. THAT'S NOT
THE REST THE RISK IS YOU HAVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE ENOUGH HEALTH
AND MAKE IT EXPENSIVE YOU HAVE
THREE FAMILIES LIVING TOGETHER
AND ONE YOU CROWDING WITH IN
THE HOME. AND THE RE THAT YOU
HAVE CRAP WITH IN THE HOME.
WHICH LEADS TO COULD WITH THE
HOME. IS BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T OR
NOT HOUSING IT'S EXPENSIVE IT'S
REALLY FOR THE CENTURY.
OVERCROWDING WITHIN HOMES.
PURSES DENSITIES IS BUILDING
MORE HOUSING FOR PEOPLE. YOU
KNOW ONE OR TWO PEOPLE IT'S
THEIR LIVING IN A UNIT AND YOU
DON'T HAVE THAT. RISK WITH AN
IDEA. BUT I ALL I JUNE THAT
THERE BEEN A NAY. BASEBALL'S
INACCURATE NARRATIVE STARTED BY
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK DIED
HOUSING DENSITY IS SOMEHOW TO
BLAME FOR COVER NINETEEN SPREAD.
NEW YORK REACTED HELLO AND LATE
THE CURVE IN NINETEEN TO
COMPARE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE BAY
AREA WHICH HAD EARLIER
EMERGENCE. TO WHAT HAPPENED IN
NEW YORK NEW YORK WAS LOW AND
LATE AT THE CITY LEVEL AND AT
THE STATE LEVEL. I'M NOT SAYING
THAT'S THE ONLY FACTOR BUT IT
WAS DEFINITELY A REAL FACTOR.
AND THEIR PET AND THEY PAID THE
PRICE. AND THE CALL BECAUSE WE
HAD THIS ONE VERY THAN CITY NEW
YORK CITY. THAT HAS HAD A
TERRIBLE EXPERIENCE WITH CODE.
THERE. WAS A LITTLE BIT OF LIKE
THAT'S THE BLAME IT WASN'T LATE
RESPONSE IS BECAUSE THE DENSITY
IN NEW YORK CITY. WELL LET'S
LOOK AT THAT. THE SECOND DANCE
THE CITY. OF LARGE CITIES IN
THE US. IS MY OWN CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. HI FOR THOSE WHO
DON'T KNOW AS OF AT LEAST A DAY
OR TWO AGO THE NUMBER OF DEATHS
FROM COVER NINETEEN SEVEN CISCO.
WAS FORTY. NOW FORTY ONE DAY.
FORTY SINCE THE BEGINNING OF A
PANDEMIC. NEW YORK JUST
ANNOUNCED A MAJOR MILESTONE BUT
IT. WENT UNDER ONE HUNDRED
DEATHS IN A SINGLE DAY. WE GOT
FORTY TWO THAT'S FORTY TOO MANY
DOES OF THE TRAGEDIES FORTY
FAMILIES THAT ARE IMPACTED
TOGETHER. BUT SAN FRANCISCO THE
SECOND BENSON CITY IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AMONG
LARGER CITIES. HAS DONE
REMARKABLY BETTER THAN NEW YORK
CITY. OR YOU LOOK AT EVEN LOS
ANGELES WHICH HAS HAD MORE
PROBLEMS IT'S IN A DIFFERENT
UNIVERSE THE NEW YORK CITY AND
THERE ARE PARTS OF LA THAT ARE
VERY VERY. DENSE WE ALSO LOOK
AT SOME OF THE DENSEST CITIES
IN THE WORLD SEOUL SOUTH KOREA
TAIPEI TAIWAN. HONG KONG TOKYO.
SOME OF THE DENSEST CITIES ON
THE PLANET. THE STRUGGLE TO
COVER NINETEEN LIKE EVERYONE
HAS. BUT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY CONTAIN AT. BECAUSE
DESPITE THEIR DENSITY DESPITE
HAVING HUGE TRANSIT SYSTEMS. IT
HAD EFFECTIVE GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE QUICK FRENTE AFFECTED.
SO THAT'S WHAT DRIVES. PROBABLY
NINETEEN LACK OF EFFECTIVE
GOVERNMENT RESPONSE NOT HOUSING
DENSITY WE ARE ALSO SEEING
INCREASINGLY LOW DENSITY THAT
LOW DENSITY AREAS SUBURBS RURAL
AREAS THAT ARE GETTING VERY
HARD HAT. WHETHER IT'S NEW
SHELL THE YORK A SUBURB THAT
GOT HIT. EVEN BEFORE NEW YORK
CITY OR OTHER SUBURBS AND RURAL
AREAS LOW DENSITY AREAS AROUND
THE COUNTRY. BECAUSE EVEN IF
YOU'RE NOT LIVING IN AN
APARTMENT. YOU'RE STILL GOING
TO THEWALMART ACOSTA FOR THE
SAFE WAY. STILL GOING TO
DIFFERENT AREAS WHERE PEOPLE
CONCRETE TOGETHER. AND YOU KNOW
I WOULD POSIT THAT BEING IN A
COST CODES CROWD IS NO
DIFFERENT THAN BEING IN A
SUBWAY. RIDE OR SEEING YOU KNOW.
IN A PART OF BILL. IF YOU KNOW
THE SO THAT'S MY GONNA. WELL
STUDY DONE. IN KAGO JR I CHINA.
COMPARING THE SPREAD ACROSS
NINETEEN. IN THE DANCE AREAS
VERSUS THE ELDER. LESS DENSE
AREA. AND ALL OF THE START HAVE.
THAT THERE IS NO AND- IN INTO
RATE. AND ANSWER. CAN COMPARE
TO THE NEARBY NINE ERROR AND TO
SAY YOU ALL THAT IT. SENATOR SO
THAT THE MY TAKE ON YOUR
QUESTION I APPRECIATE
OPPORTUNITY. AND THANK YOU
PROFESSOR. ANY FURTHER QUEST.
GARAGE PLATE YEAH JUST. I JUST
WANT TO ADD TO MY COMMENTS
ABOUT THE- OVERCROWDING. THIS.
MY DISEASE IN MY DISTRICT
OVERCROWDED NEIGHBORHOODS HAVE
FOUR TO SIX PEOPLE PER ROOM.
THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AND A SOLUTION
FOR THEM FOR THOSE FAMILIES FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES. IS NOT A BY
RIGHT DENSITY. OF THE SOLUTION
FOR THEM IS DIFFERENT IT'S
ABOUT FUNDING IT'S ABOUT
PRIORITIZING THEM AND SO I JUST
YOU KNOW. I'M NOT OPPOSING THE
IDEA OF A BY RIGHT YOU KNOW
INCREASE IN DENSITY I JUST
THINK THAT THERE ARE CERTAIN
KEY NEIGHBORHOODS BUT THAT'S
NOT THE SOLUTION FOR WHICH IS
WHAT I'M ASKING YOU TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION. AND I
FRAZIER THAT'S ANOTHER ALSO AND
I AGREE WITH YOU ACTUALLY A
100% IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
SOLUTIONS ARE AND- MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS BECOMING A-
RELEVANT I BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CALL- ON SOON FROM SENATOR- PAT
BATES. YES HERE I AM HI. YOU
HEAR ME GUYS WE CAN YES WE CAN
SEE AND HEAR A I JUST WANTED TO
LET SEEK A SENATOR WIENER FOR
PUTTING LOCAL GOVERNMENT BACK
INTO THE DISCUSSION ON THE
DANCE VACATION PROPOSED. TO
HELP WITH OUR HOUSE ON YOU KNOW
SENATOR WINNER MY OPPOSITION TO
A NUMBER OF THE BILLS HAD
MOSTLY TO DO WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY- WHICH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TAKE VERY SERIOUSLY DESIGNER
YEAH HAVING YOU KNOW SIR MANY
YEARS ABOUT WELL AND I KNOW OUR
PLANNING COMMISSION WHICH ALSO
HAS. YES OUR FOCUS PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES THEN THE TRAY
THAT OCCURRED IN MY COMMUNITY
MAY YEARS WITH. KANTOR GOVERNOR
WALKS GOING. AGAINST THE- A
KILLED AND JOB ANOTHER AT EIGHT
SIGN ACTUALLY ON THAT WAS BE OF
THE PARK CARS SO OVER THE ROOM
SO IT'S GIVEN OFFERED FOR LOW
GUN TO BE AT THE TWO. TO SEARCH
AND HW FOR THE NEW THAT ARE
BUT DO IT IN A VERY I THINK
QUALITY WAY. THAT'S ALL WE CAN
ASK FOR PRE SHAPE WHICH BROUGHT
THEM BACK TO TABLE ON THIS BILL.
THE MATCH. REGARDING THE
CROWDING AND SHORT TERM
RENTALS- BECAUSE THIS BILL DOES
NOT IN ANY WAY LIMIT THE
ABILITY OF CITIES TO EXERCISE
THEIR CURRENT POWER TO BAN. OR
RESTRICT OR REGULATE SHORT TERM
RENTALS I AGREE WE DON'T WANT
THESE TO BECOME. HOTELS AND THE
CITIES WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO WHATEVER IT
IS THEY CHOOSE TO DO IT SPECTER
SHORT TERM RENTALS- AND IN
TERMS OF CROWDING AGAIN CITIES
CAN DECIDE. THIS NEIGHBORHOOD
ALREADY TO DANCE WE DON'T WANT
TO BE MORE THAN TO WANT TO GO
OVER HERE AND THEY CAN MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS SO I THINK
THESE ARE VERY VALID. CONCERNS
AND WE VERY INTENTIONALLY
TRYING TO GIVE A CITIES TO
CONTINUE WITH ALREADY TO MAKE
LOW ALL THIS TENDS. JENNIFER
THE- I WANT I DO WANT TO POINT
OUT THIS BUILT THE BUILDING
TRADES LETTER TO MY CAR. YOU
WERE MISTER HOW. THAT THE
OBJECTS IS NOW. IS NOT ABOUT-
TWO TO TEN UNITS WHICH IS WHAT
THIS BILL POTENTIALLY ALLOWS
IT'S A CONCERN THAT IN THE
FUTURE A FUTURE BILL WILL
EXTEND SB NO TO. A LARGER
AMOUNT HIGHER THAN TEN UNITS
WHICH IS STILL DOESN'T DO. AND
WANTING PROTECTIONS. TEXANS
RELATING TO THE FUTURE OF FOR-
WE'RE GONNA TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WE CAN. I KNOW.
BY THE FUTURE. NINE STILL BUT
DISTILLING ON IS NOT TRIGGER
THE CONCERNS THAT I'M READING
IN THE BUILDING TRADES LETTER.
MY COLLEAGUES ARE THIS IS A
GOOD BILL BUT I THINK BALANCES.
ARE FOR HOUSING. AND DIFFERS
SIGNIFICANTLY TO CITIES TO MAKE
LOCAL DECISIONS. THAT NEW ONE
POWERFUL TOOLS I RESPECT US FOR
I. OKAY OKAY WE THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER WE DO HAVE A
MOTION ON SB NINE ALL TO IT WAS
MOVED BY SENATOR ROTH SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
SENATE BILL NINE OH TWO BY
SENATOR WINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WINNER
BY WINNER I MORAL. MORRELL NOT
VOTING. ZERO FIVE ZERO FIVE
DORADO HI DORADO HIGH WIRE.
MORE LOOK. WHAT MOORLACH I'D
ROTH AYE ROTH AYE SKINNER
SKINNER AYE NUMBER NUMBER HI
WITH CASKEY. HI CASKEY I'D-
EIGHT BUCKS. THERE ARE EIGHT
VOTES WE WILL LEAVE- THE ROLE
OPEN FOR CENTER- MCGUIRE. OKAY
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES I KNOW I
WILL- TO THE GOBBLED
FIGURATIVELY BACK TO THE VICE
CHAIR. WE WILL NOW GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FOUR- WHICH IS A
TUESDAY- THANK CALENDAR ITEM
NUMBER WHAT WILL IT TO THE
CONCERNED BECAUSE THE NOT ITEM
FOR. A IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SO MOVED SB TEN THIRTY THAT
THING ON THE MOST BILL MOTION
BY CENTER LIKE CAL SKI. I AM
CAN WE PLEASE. CALL THE ROLL.
ON THE CALENDAR WHICH CONSISTS
OF FILE ITEM FOR SENATE BILL
TEN THIRTY BY THE COMMITTEE ON
HOUSING SENATOR WINNER ALL
RIGHT WIENER HI MORAL HIGH
MORAL AYE CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO I'D TO RUSSELL HEY
TORONTO HIGH WIRE. MORE LUCK BY
MORE LIKE A HIGH ROTH HI ROTH
AYE SKINNER. INNER AYE NUMBER
NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI BY WITH
CASKEY I NINE ABOUT NINE
NOTHING IT HAS ENOUGH VOTES AND
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLL OVER FOR
SENATOR MCGUIRE OKAY WILL NEXT
GO TO ITEM NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS
SB TEN NINETY FIVE A CENTER
CENTER CENTER THE FOUR ZERO
FIVE THANK YOU MARCH TWO. STILL
THEY OPEN WITH THE EXCEPT
HOUSING MEMONS. AND I ALSO TO
ADDRESS CAN. THAT WERE RAISED-
RECENTLY. I WILL BE AND I
REALIZE IT WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
DO THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE BUT-
WILL DO IT IF IT MOVES ON TO A
PROBES BUT I'M JUST MAKING MY
VERBAL COMMITMENT TO DELETE
SECTION KATE THREE BE- THEY'LL
BE IN A ADDITIONAL SLIGHT FIX
AND- CLEAR FOR CATION ON. THE
OTHER WORDS WHERE WHERE I
DISCUSS THE ISSUE OF. FEES
INCLUSIONARY FEES THAT I WOULD
JUST USE I WOULD JUST MOVE THE
WORD AFFORDABLE TO THE SO THAT
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THE ONLY
FEES THAT I AM TRYING TO
INFLUENCE IN THIS BILL SO THAT
THEY WOULD NOT BE COUNTED ON
THE BONUS UNITS BECAUSE IT'S A
DOUBLE COUNTING. ARE AFFORDABLE
FEE SO I WOULD ON A- BEING
CLEAR ABOUT WHAT. WOULD BE
MOVING THAT WORD OF OR I'D BE
INSERTING NETWORK AFFORDABLE SO
IT'S CLEAR THAT IT'S AFFORDABLE.
FEES IN LIEU IT CETERA
ETCETERA. WITH THAT I WILL
BONUS
VERY IMPORTANT TOOL TO
INCENTIVIZE MARKET RATE
PROJECTS TO INCLUDE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. HOWEVER WHAT WE
HAVE FOUND IN THE RESEARCH IS
THAT LESS THAN ONE HALF OF ALL
OF THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE APPROVED FRIDAY
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE DENSITY
BONUS NOW SOME OF THAT IS JUST
YOU KNOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A
NOTE HOUSING. BUT SOME OF IT
IS. THAT THERE'S BEEN IN
DISTANCE SEE IN THE ADOPTION OF
RULES BY THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT ARE UNNECESSARILY. THE BIT
DENSITY BONUS LAW. IN
ADDITIONALLY THE- THE BUILDERS
HAVE JUST OPTED NOT TO YOUR
LICENSE SO SINCE. THIS IS. TO
INCREASE AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE-
STATUTE IS DESIGNED SO THAT IT
ACTUALLY EXCEPT FOR THAT'S WHAT
WE WANT. WE HAVE. ONE HERE. THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN CAL. FOR
THE DAY TONY. HAND IF YOU. YOU
LOOK AT THOSE THAT HAVE THE
ROLE WITHIN ONE TO TWO PROUD TO
PROVE IN. SO THIS GREAT TO.
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITHIN THE MARKET RE
PROJECTS IT'S NOT QUITE PULLING
OFF WHAT WE HOPED. SO WHAT SB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE DOES IS CLARIFY
THAT THE STATE STATUTE AND
LOCAL LAWS WILL COUNT THE
NUMBER OF NUMBER OF AFFORDABLE
UNITS REQUIRED IN THE SAME
MANNER. IT ALSO- WELL IT IS
ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL THAT WE
NEED MORE HOUSING FOR LOW IN
VERY LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS.
THE DENSITY BONUSES ALSO ALLOWS
FOR THE IN MY OF A MODERATE
INCOME A AM I OF 8210020% BUT
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT IN OUR
VERY HIGH HOUSING COSTS AREAS
OF CALIFORNIA LIKE THE BAY AREA
AND THE JOB RICH PARTS OF LA
AND SAN DIEGO THE MIDDLE INCOME
CAN NOT AFFORD HOUSING IN THE
DENSITY BONUS NOT RESULTED IN
ANY UNITS FOR THAT SEGMENT. SB
EIGHTY FIVE DOES PROVIDE AN
ADJUSTMENT FOR THE HIGH HOUSING
COST AREAS THAT THEY COULD
UTILIZE. IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
UNITSFOR FAMILIES WITHIN THAT
82100% OF EIGHTY VERY INCOME.
SO LASTLY THE TEN EIGHTY FIVE
ALSO INCREASES THE UNIT BONUS
FROM 35240% FOR. EVERYONE BELOW
50% OF MEDIAN SO LOW IN VERY
LOW. AND IT- ENCOURAGES THE D.
B. THE DENSITY BONUS TO BE USED
FOR STUDENT HOUSING PROJECTS BY
ALLOWING THOSE STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT INCLUDE VERY LOW.
INCOME AFFORDABLE UNITS TO
UTILIZE AN ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE
AND I THINK ALL OF US KNOW THAT
WE'VE SEEN OVER THE LAST X.
NUMBER OF YEARS A VERY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN
HOMELESS STUDENTS IN STUDENTS
WHO ARE HUNGER CHALLENGED
INCREASING USE OF RELIANCE ON
FOOD- NOR CAL. THIS PROGRAM. SO
WE ARE FINDING MORE AND MORE
STUDENTS IN NEED OF VERY
AFFORDABLE UNITS FINALLY THIS
BILL CONFORMS THE DENSITY BONUS
APPROVAL WITH REQUIREMENTS IN
OUR STATE HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACTING WITH
THAT'LL TURN MY WITNESSES DAVID
GARCIA FROM THE TURNER CENTER
AND CYNTHIA PARKER FROM BRIDGE
SHOPPING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTERS SKINNER AND FROM IS
PARKER MISTER GARCIA. YOU WILL
HAVE THREE MINUTES. TOTAL SO IF
YOU WANT TO SPLIT IT NINETY
SECONDS EACH JUST MAKE SURE TO
TIME YOURSELVES YOU DON'T.
CONSUME THE OTHERS SPEAKERS
TIME- SO I WILL START WITH.
OTHERS FIRST. I THINK OF ALL
THREE IF YOU DON'T MIND THANK
YOU PARKER AND I'M THE
PRESIDENT AND C. E. O. OF
BRIDGE HELPING. UP FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO DON'T KNOW BREAK. CAN
ABOUT THIRTY EIGHT YEARS. ALL
WE CREATED ABOUT NINETEEN
THOUSAND UNITS I HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND RESIDENTS
LIVING IN OUR HOUSING ARE
PORTABLE HELPING- WE HAVE ABOUT
A BILLION FIND IN CONSTRUCTION
RIGHT NOW ELEVEN THOUSAND UNITS
IN OUR PIPELINE. SO WE'RE VERY
SOON BEGAN TO THE NEED OR SHARP
OF TOOLS IN OUR TOOL BOX IN
ORDER TO CREATE. MORE HOUSING
WE WANT TO REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
THE BELT BECAUSE- WE DO NEED A
TOOL IN PLACE. AND PRIOR EIGHT
CATCHES NOT VERY AFFECT TOOL
AND AIDED BY IN ORDER SKINNER.
THE ECONOMIC OF THE CURRENT AND
PEOPLE THAT DID NOT UP TO
MARKET WE FELL TO DEDICATE.
MORE AFFORDABLE YOU AND THEN
YOU GRAB BUT THE BILLION THE
BILL ALLOW ALLOW FOR KIND YET
ADDING TO THE AFRICAN OVERALL.
I IN ADDITION I WE LACK THE
PROVISION FOR UP GREEN ACCOUNT
ACT WHICH BRED ONE TO ADD BEEN
PRETTY. THE CURRENT EIGHT
CATCHES FOR AND HOW PERCENT OF
PROJECT AND THE CITY HELPING OF
PLANNING ON THE CURRENT IT DOWN
THEY DIDN'T WANT PRESIDENT. THE
STATE. CATCH YOU ALTHOUGH THE
THIRD QUARTER OUR GIFT TO BE
CLASS WE'RE NOW. THREE PRACTICE
IN THE IN IN THEIR TO PLANNING
ZONING. TAKING NOT LONGER THAT.
I AM DEFINITELY WITH HOUSING
THE AT THE CLEAR THAT OUT I
YOU'RE CONSIDERING OF THE BILL
AND THANK YOU FOR TIME. THE
SERVICE HERE. GOOD MORNING-
CHAIRED THANK YOU- IN THE MUSIC
ANY OTHER WELL MY NAME IS DAVID
GARCIA ON THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE TERMS IN ADDRESSING THE
UC BERKELEY I'M HERE THIS
MORNING TO SOME OF OUR RESEARCH
ON THE YOU DON'T A SONG LIKE
CHANGES TO THE- OUR- SO. AS A
RESEARCH SHOWN STATE THE
EXISTING YOU'RE GOING TO LAW
WHICH IS INTENDED DRIVE FOR MY
HUSBAND YOU THEN MARKER AND
WITHOUT CITY IS NOT LIFE TO
YEARS SPECIFICALLY ARE TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA RESIDENTIAL
LAND USE SURVEY FOUND THAT FROM
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY SEVEN
TEEN ONLY 45% JURISDICTIONS AT
ANY DEVELOPMENT BUT YOU LIED TO
DANTE BONUS IN MOST OF THESE
PLACES ONLY HAD ONE OR TWO
PROJECTS- FURTHER ONLY.
FOURTEEN TO OUR SURVEY HAD
THREE OR MORE THAN ONCE PER IN.
SO ALL OF THIS TELL THE THAT
THE- HONEST. STRUCTURE TODAY IS
WORKING AS WELL AS IT COULD
IDEALLY MORE PROJECTS SHOULD
WORK WITH THE DENTAL BONUS
LEADING TO MORE DEALERSHIP
UNITS. HELLO WORLD SO TO THAT
END. OF FORMS TO THIS LAW ARE
OVERDUE. AND A STRENGTHENED AND
HE BONUS CONCERT IS AN
IMPORTANT PIECE OF OUR- OUR
HOUSING CONSIDER US WHICH IS
WHY WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
KIND OF POLICY THAT THE CORD.
BY SENATE BILL. SO ONLY WITH
THEIR. OWN A- MANY THINK CHAIR
AND THE AUTHOR HER WERE ON
ISSUE I. THANK VERY MUCH WILL
NOW GO TO ANY SUPPORT. HERE AND
CHAMBER UP IN THE GALLERY-
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME.
COLLATION AND POSITION. A GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DEBRA CARLTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. OKAY IS
THAT THE ONLY. ONE MR REST OF.
OKAY ONE SO IN ORDER TO ROUTE
TWENTY FORTY. SERVER DESOLATE
OVER THERE NO ONE IN TWENTY
FORTY- SO NOW GO TO THE PHONE
LINES- TO THE MODERATOR TO
ANYONE ONLINE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE CALLING FOR
IMMEDIATE THAT. ONE AND THAT IS
TO STATE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. WE'LL GO TO LINE
NUMBER AT THE NINE ZERO NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
ROBERT NEAL REPRESENTING IF
YOU'LL SEVEN COMPANY AN ORANGE
COUNTY BUSINESS STRONGLY
SUPPORT OF A CALIFORNIA YOU ME
AND WE ARE THE STRONGEST OF
ORDER SB TEN EIGHTY FIVE. MY
NUMBER ONE ZERO NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME AT
THE PHILADELPHIA CRANK CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE THREE PIECE
COALITION WHICH INCLUDES
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME THE SAN
FRANCISCO FOUNDATION. PARTNERS
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE MODERATE AYE
NUMBER EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I GET MY- HI I'M NOT
SURE MEMBERS LUIS BURNT DOWN
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIAN BEAKER
TOPPERS OR AS WELL THANK YOU.
LINE NUMBER NINE NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN NINETY NINE. GREATER
HONOR WITH CARPENTER SIEVERS ON
BEHALF OF SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC
NORTH AMERICA IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. MY NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE.
COREY SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA HOUSING ADVOCACY
COALITION IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY
FIVE. LINE NUMBER. FIVE MELISSA
WARNER ON BEHALF OF THE SILICON
VALLEY COMMUNITY FOUNDATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
EIGHTY NINE. ABBY KIDDING
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. LINE
NUMBER SIXTEEN. THE BILL DEAL
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF CITY SPOKE
IN SUPPORT. LINE NUMBER
NINETEEN. I THANK YOU THAT YOU
ARE BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE WILL BE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THE BILL-
ONCE WE SEE THE MOMENT IT
CENTER SKINNER DESCRIBING HER
OPENING STATEMENT. PEOPLE
WORKING WITH THE INTERSTATE.
LINE NUMBER. NINETY FIVE. MY
NINETY FIVE COULD LINE IS OPEN.
GEORGE WAS AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION WE HAD A SUPPORT
GIVE AMENDED PETITION- BUT
WOULD LIKE TO THE LANGUAGE ON
THE DEFINITION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING FEES ANDWITH THOSE
CHANGES AND WE THINK E'RE
GONNA GO TO FULL SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR WORKING WITH
THAT. MY NUMBER THIRTY TWO.
KIMBERLY DONE THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. IF THERE ANY
FURTHER IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER IN SUPPORT. OKAY A KEY
TO DO ONE MORE CALL FOR ME TO
USE IN SUPPORT. IF ANYONE IS
WHAT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THE TIME. THE MIAMI
UNIT. AND WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. AM I AND NEEDED. YES
THIS. ALI FOR MANY WHAT I HAVE
TO LOOK AT A MAP OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
OKAY MODERATOR KEEP FIFTY ONE
FINAL CALL FOR SUPPORT. IS
THERE ANY FURTHER AND SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OKAY THAT AND THE SUPPORT
COMMENT WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSE-
WILL START HERE IN THE GALLERY
I SEE MR ACOSTA WHO I THINK
WILL BE PROVIDING THE LEAD.
OPPOSITION WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
ELSE SO MR ACOSTA YOU HAVE UP
TO THREE MINUTES. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BRIAN AUGUSTA
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND THE
CALFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION- WE
SHARED OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
AUTHOR BUT MISTER CHAIRMAN I
DON'T WANT TO DIRECT MY
COMMENTS TO SOMETHING THAT MAY
BE COMING OUT AND- MISSED. WHAT
CENTER SKINNER. WAS IS REMOVING
AND THE NEXT COMMITTEE SO IF WE
COULD IF I COULD ASK FOR
CLARIFICATION ON THAT. IS A
PIECE OF THE BILL THAT SENATOR
SANDERS AS LOU WAS COMING OUT.
OKAY NORMALLY WHAT IT IS THAT
IS THAT IF YOU WANT TO VERY
QUICKLY SAY WHAT'S RIGHT NOW
LIKE TO DO IS. I WOULD
APPRECIATE IF THE OPPOSITION
WOULD DESCRIBE THEIR OPPOSITION
AND I WILL INDICATE A VARIETY
OF THINGS IN MY CLOTHES OKAY SO
YOU CAN PROCEED GIVE US SHERMAN
HAS. YOUR TIME. I'M A- PART
CONCERT. OR TWO FULL. ONE IS
THAT. THE BILL- THAT IS IN
PRINT. WOULD EXPAND THE DENSITY
BONDS LAW TO COVER MODERATE
INCOME HOUSING. TO ALLOW THE
DENSITY BONUS TO BE USED. FOR
UNITS THAT ARE AFFORDABLE. TO
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
WHICH WE THINK WILL RESULT IN.
THE LOG BEING UTILIZED. IN A
WAY THAT WILL. FINISH
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING FOR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WE TAKE.
WHAT WE SHOULD FOCUS OUR
EFFORTS IS IN USING THIS
IMPORTANT- LAW. THAT OVERRIDES
LOCAL ZONING CONTROLS TO
PROVIDE SOME INCENTIVES FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF HOUSING TO FOCUS
SAID WE'RE HOUSING PRODUCTION
IS MOST NEEDED. AND IN MOST
AREAS OF THE STATE THAT IS FOR
THE PRODUCTION HOUSING FOR LOW
AND VERY LOW. ALSO CONCERNED.
WITH THE PROVISIONS WHICH WOULD
EXPAND THE INCENTIVES FOR
STUDENT HOUSING THAT IS A
FAIRLY NEW PIECE OF THAT ANTI
BONUS LAW. THE ECONOMICS OF THE
STRUCTURE OF THOSE KINDS OF
DEALS ARE MUCH DIFFERENT WE
THINK OF THAT PERMITTED AND
THEN EXISTING LAWS SHOULD BE
GIVEN SOME ADDITIONAL TIME. TO
WORK BEFORE WE START MAKING
ADJUSTMENTS BUT IF WE ARE GOING
TO MAKE ADJUSTMENTS TO GIVE
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVES FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF THAT. FORM OF
HOUSING WE SHOULD DO SO IN A
WAY THAT ENSURES THAT WE GET
GREATER AFFORDABILITY THERE ARE
MANY STUDENTS. WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND HOUSING THEY
CAN AFFORD IT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE MAXIMIZING THE
PRODUCTION OF UNITS. FOR THAT
POPULATION AND GIVING AWAY
INCIDENTS WITHOUT INCREASING.
THE AFFORDABILITY DOES NOT DO
THAT SO FOR THOSE REASONS. WE
HAVE AN APOSTLE AS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WE
HOPE TO CONTINUE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. AS THE BILL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR SERVICE- ON
IS THERE ARE I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER COMMENTERS IN THE GALLERY
SO MOVED TO TWENTY FORTY.
TWENTY FORTY IS STILL EMPTY-
WILL GO TO THE TELECONFERENCE
ONLINE- TO MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND IN GENERAL AT THE
TIME WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
OKAY WE JUST HAD OF A DRIVE BY
TO KEEP. THANK YOU LEYVA
DETERMINE IF YOU'RE OPPOSITION
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND WE WILL GO THROUGH THE LINE
OF NINETY THREE NINETY THREE
UNITED OPEN. LINE NUMBER NINETY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE
HAD NO RESPONSE FROM NINETY
THREE IF ANYONE IS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. IN
NINETY THREE THROWING UP.
NINETY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THE CLUB HEAD. HI DAVID ON ON
BEHALF OF COD CO A NONPROFIT
HOUSING PROVIDER AN ADVOCACY
GROUP AND- THANK. OFFICE THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO MORE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY JUST ONE FINAL
CALL. YEAH THE GENTLEMAN IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND THERE ARE NO MORE IN
OPPOSITION OKAY I THINK YOU'RE
WRONG WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. A CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR- AND DIE I WANNA
COMMENDED THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL- THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT
DENSITY BONUS LIES ONE OF THE-
PREMIER WAYS THAT WE CAN GET-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNITS BUILT
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I
JUST WANNA. BE ONE NOTE OF
CAUTION AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS
ON. A WORK IN PROGRESS FORGET
IT THERE'S A WAYS TO GET IT I
THINK TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE
BUT- THERE ARE MANY COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN WORKING. VERY
DILIGENTLY. WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING HOUSING WORD AND
ORDINANCES AS ROBUST AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT IT CAN.
REALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY. AND SO I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T BàN
WIPE THAT OFF. THE FACE OF THE
EARTH IN ADOPTING A NEW DENSITY
BONUS LAW. AND IN PARTICULAR
THE ISSUE IS- THE. CHANGE THIS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL WHICH
WOULD ALLOW THE DAY THAT THE
DENSITY BONUS TO SATISFY ALL OF
THE LOCAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- IN MY
REGION IF YOU ELECT TO USE THE
DENSITY BONUS AND THEN HAVE TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AS
PART OF THAT DENSITY BONUS IT
HASN'T NECESSARILY MEET THE
REQUIREMENT. FOR THE LOCAL
JURIST AND THAT THE DENSITY
BONUS ARE THAT EXCUSE ME THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING INCLUSIONARY
HOUSING ORDINANCE THAT THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION HAS PASSED
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THAT FOR THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
THIS. THAT I'VE LOOKED AT. THE.
THE DENSITY LEVELS FOR VERY LOW
LOW MODERATE AND- ABOVE THAT
THAT WERE NOT BEEN COMING IN
INTERNET AND TRANSFERRING OUR
OWN IDEA OF WHAT SHOULD WORK IN
THE COMMUNITY. THANK YOU
SENATOR DROSS OF. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I KNOW- MY
COLLEAGUES CENTER SKINNER
WORKS- VERY VERY HARD ON THESE
ISSUES- BUT I DO HAVE TO RAISE
THE ISSUE- ABOUT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ART PIECE OF IT. WE ALL
KNOW THAT THE SHORTAGE IN LOW
VERY LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW- HOW
INCOME HOUSING IS JUST AT A
BIGGEST OUR BIGGEST CRISIS
LEVEL. WHEN THE HUNT ONE FOUR
MILLION AFFORDABLE HOMES ARE
NEEDED- AND SO- THIS ISSUE OF
INCENTIVIZE THE BUILDING
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING WHEN
THE HIGHEST NEED ISN'T LOW
INCOME HOUSING I THINK IS AN
ISSUE OF EQUITY- SO I WONDER
RAISE THAT TO THE TO THE
AUTHOR- AND SECOND ONE TWO I
DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT YOU'RE- WORKING
ON UP ON. IS THAT HOW
DEVELOPMENT CAN COULD BYPASS
LABOR STANDARDS SO- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THIRDS GONNA REALLY
LIKE TO RESPOND THE. REMAIN
CLOSER TO REFER- I'M HAPPY TO
DO SO MY IN MY CLOTHES IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FEDERAL ACCOUNTS HERE. I
AGENCIES I GUESS A
CLARIFICATION- I'M READING ON
PAGE TWO OF THE ANALYSIS IF
YOU. WERE LOOKING AT BEDROOMS
TO DETERMINE HOW MANY PARKING
SPACES PEOPLE. YOU ARE REQUIRED
WITH THE AFFORDABLE UNITS AND
THEN IF YOU HAVE A 100%
AFFORDABLE AND WITHIN A HALF
MILE TRANSIT YOU GET A HALF
UNIT I HAVE SPACE PER ACRE.
WHAT WAS HIS I GUESS WHO WHY DO
WE NEED TO GET TO A 100%
AFFORDABLE IF WE'RE AT 80% THAT
WE WOULDN'T HAVE THE SAME
INCENTIVES- SAME. OF A VALUE OF
HAVING LESS PARKING AND LESS
NEED FOR PARKING AND PERHAPS
MORE UNITS BUILT. EARN DOES
SENATOR MINERALS I CAN ADDRESS
THAT AND THEN ALSO DO MY
CLOTHES WHAT WHICHEVER YOU
PREFER OKAY OKAY AND AGAIN IN A
FINALLY AND IT'S ON THE
OPPOSITION I GUESS DEPOSITION
SEEMS TO INDICATE AND PUTTING
ASIDE THE STUDENT HOUSING THIS
IS THAT. PEOPLE NOT
WITHSTANDING THE HOUSING
ELEMENT OR HOUSING- THE RENO
NUMBERS REQUIRING PEOPLE TO
BUILD VERY LOW AN EXTREMELY LOW
HOUSING THERE. THE MAGES BUILD
MODERATELY LOW HOUSING GIVEN
THE ECONOMICS SO HI SURE
CONCERNED WITH AND I'M WILLING
TO OBVIOUSLY TO WORK IN
PROGRESS AND- WE'RE HAVING A
SPECIAL CONSIDERATIONS DAVID
THAT SEEMS TO BE A LEGITIMATE
ISSUE. WITH MISTER CHAIR FOR
THE OKAY OFFERED TO ANSWER WILL
HOLD UP FOR THE CLOTHES IF
THAT'S OKAY CENTER NINETY ONE
RESPOND NOW. WHAT ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS MEMBERS.
OKAY ODD SEEING NINE- AND IS
THERE A MOTION ON THIS. ON THE
WAY OKAY- AND BEFORE YOU CLOSE
THE MOTION IS TO SEND THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AS
AMENDED- CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF ISSUES REYES RONA SO-
SO- LET'S SEE. OF TRADER
ADDRESS THEM ALL- ANDI ISSUE OF
THE- I BELIEVE SENATOR DRAWS
ARE RAISED AROUND. WHO MY BRAIN
ISN'T WORKING- THE SECOND PART-
AT THAT IS ONE OF THE MEMBERS
ON TAKING. OKAYSO APOLOGIES
HEIGHTENS IT NOW IN THE ISSUE
OF. THIS BILL DOES NOT REDUCE
THE REQUIREMENT FOR EITHER VERY
LOW INCOME OR LOW INCOME
AFFORDABLE UNITS WHAT IT DOES
IS ALLOW FOR IN THE HIGH COST
AREAS A POTENTIAL EXPANSION OF
WHAT'S CONSIDERED A MODERATE
INCOME NOW OBVIOUSLY THERE IS
SOME. DEBATE ABOUT WHETHER
THAT'S NECESSARY OR NOT- AND
WHAT. THE REASON IT'S INCLUDED
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MANY
PEOPLE IN THESE HIGH COST AREAS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING. AND
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS THAT
WHILE WE WHILE WE ADOPTED AND
DESIGNED TO THIS DENSITY BONUS
LAW TO TRY FOR THE INTENTION OF
INCREASING AFFORDABLE UNITS. WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THAT NUMBER WE'VE
NOT SEEN THE READ THE NUMBER OF
UNITS THAT WE HOPED SO IN THE
REALLY HIGH COST AREAS WE ARE
SEEING MUCH LESS TAKE UP. OF
THE PROVISION OF THE REALLY
AFFORDABLE BECAUSE THE
ECONOMICS OF THE BUILDING COSTS
THE PROPERTY COSTS THE LABOR
COSTS THIS OTHER FEES THAT THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PUT TO ALL
THOSE THINKS THE WHOLE NUMBER.
JUST MAKES THE PER UNIT COST SO
EXPENSIVE THAT THE BUILDERS ARE
NOT OPTING IN OBVIOUSLY
BUILDERS IFTHE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AS SOON CERTAIN WAY
THEY HAVE THE RIGHT TO BUILD
IT'S REALLY ELECTIVE ON THEM AS
TO WHETHER THEY UTILIZE STUDENT
THE BILL. SO TURN TO IS
MOTIVATE THEM TO UTILIZE IT
MORE AND BECAUSE WE KNOW THERE
IS THIS. NEAT FOR OUR HOUSE FOR
EXAMPLE I. THE SOFT SERVICE
TYPE A WORKER THAT IN A LOT OF
THEORIES OF OUR STATE JUST
CANNOT AFFORD HOUSING SO BUT
THERE'S THIS YOU I AM NOT
TRYING TO DILUTE THE VERY LOW
FOR THE LOW INCOME ASPECT AND
SO IT'S JUST ONE OF THESE. WED
KNIVES AND DEBATES BEYOND. I
WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
WELL IT'S NOT BEFORE US
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ IS
CARRYING A BILL THAT WOULD
GREATLY INCREASE THE
REQUIREMENT UNDER THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW FOR THE VERY
AFFORDABLE. AND I COMPLETELY
SUPPORT THOSE PROVISIONS AND I
WOULD HAVE INCLUDED THOSE
PROVISIONS BUT I DID NOT WANT
TO JUST DUPLICATE. HER LAW. AND
SO I SEE THEM AS VERY MUCH
COMPLIMENTARY AT SOME POINT WE
MAY HAVE TO MERGE THEM- BUT I
SEE THEM AS VERY CALM MEANT
THREE AM VERY MUCH SUPPORTER
LAW. THERE ARE THINGS IN THE
BILL IN TEN EIGHTY FIVE THAT
ARE NOT IN HERS. ONE FOUR X.
THE ISSUE AROUND. WITH THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT AND
VARIOUS OTHER THINGS. AND SO
THAT IS WHY BY CONTINUED WITH
MY BILL NOW. I AM OPEN AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS TO
ADDRESS THIS MODERATE INCOME
THING BECAUSE MY POINT IS NOT
TO DISCOURAGE OR ELIMINATE THE
USE OF THE DENSITY BONUS FOR
VERY AFFORDABLE UNITS IT IS. SO
WELL. THERE WILL BE AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION THEIR RELATIONSHIP
TO THE STUDENT HOUSING. I
CERTAINLY AM WILLING TO LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN INCREASE THE VERY
AFFORDABILITY BECAUSE MY WHOLE
INTENT OF INCLUDING STUDENT
HOUSING IN THIS BILL WAS
BECAUSE OF THE NAME OF THE NEW
REAL NEAT THAT THE WAR FINDING
WAS STUDENTS WHERE THEY CAN.
AFFORD EVEN DORMS SO I
CERTAINLY- WE CAN RE LOOK AT
THAT LANGUAGE AND SEE WHAT
IMPROVEMENTS WE CAN MAKE. AND
THAT TOO SENATOR COVERS POINT.
HI I THINK ANY AND WE WILL RE
LOOK AT IT BUT- THE- THE BILL
AS WRITTEN DOES NOT ELIMINATE
LOCAL ORDINANCES IT'LL IT THERE
SOME CONFORMITY FIXES BUT THEY
CAN STILL ADOPT ORDINANCES THAT
ARE MORE LIBERAL. SO AGAIN WE
AND IF YOU IF YOU WANT YOUR
STAFF OR THE ENTITY THAT RACE
THAT WE CAN SIT DOWN WITH MY
STAFF AND GO THROUGH AND MAKE
SURE. THAT I HAVE- THAT IT IS
DOING WHAT I INTEND AND IS NOT
DOING WHAT TIME YOU DESCRIBE
THAT WOULD. HE FINALLY. ON THE
ISSUE OF THE CHANGE IN THE
PARKING. THE YEAH AND THOSE YOU
KNOW TO ME THAT PART IS
RELATIVELY MINIMAL ARE NOT
MINIMAL BUT NOT ESSENTIAL TO
WHAT I'M TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
IN THE BILL AND IF IT REALLY
GIVES PEOPLE A LOT OF HEADACHE
I COULD LET GO OF IT BUT IT WAS
ONE OF THOSE WHERE. WORKED MY
WHOLE PURPOSE IS TO JUST TRY TO
IMPROVE. IMPROVE AND INCREASE
THE USE I WANT THE DENSITY
BONUS LAW TO BE USE SO THAT'S
THE POINT OF IT AND WE BASED
THIS VERY MUCH ON THE RESEARCH
REPORT THAT THE BERNICE TURNER
CENTER DID. AND I CERTAIN OPEN
THREE VISIONS AS IT MOVES
THROUGH BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT TO GET AT THE CORE
ELEMENTS OF IT THAT ARE GOING
TO BUY BASED ON THE RESEARCH
INCREASE THE USE OF THE TOOL
BUT I CERTAINLY WILL RE LOOK AT
THE LANGUAGE IN THE MODERATE
PART TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
NOT. UNDERMINE THE TOOLS USE
FOR AFFORDABLE UNITS IN WITH
ACT I HOPE THAT YOU I WILL
RECEIVE YOUR ACT OF. THANK YOU
OUR MOTION. WILL CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY
FIVE BY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WINNER
HI WINNER I'D MORALE. CABALLERO
HI ZERO HI TORONTO HEY TO
RUSSELL I AM A CHOIR. MORE LOOK.
MORE LIKE A FIVE RUN BY BIRTH I
SKINNER SKINNER AYE NUMBER
NUMBER FIVE WE CASKEY BY WITH
CASKEY I. EIGHT BUT IF IT
PROCEEDS ENOUGH WE'RE GONNA PUT
IT CALL FOR- SENATOR MCGUIRE I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I AM NOW
ARE GOING TO GO SLIGHTLY OUT OF
ORDER BECAUSE HE CENTER
PORTANTINO IS HERE- CYNICAL
ITEM SEVEN SB TWELVE NINETY
NINE BY SENATOR PORTANTINO-
SENATOR YOU. MAY PRESENT. THANK
YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
ME WITH SB TWELVE NINETY NINE
WHICH WILL GIVE INCENTIVES TO
CITIES TO CONVERT ABANDON
RETAIL SITES AND BUILDINGS INTO
AFFORDABLE AND WORK FORCE
HOUSING- THE FISCAL INCENTIVES
BUT WE USED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REPLACE THE SALES TAX REVENUE
FROM THESE OTHERWISE VACANT-
RETAIL BIG BOX STORES- WE ALL
KNOW AND YOU OF ALL BEEN. WITH
IT ALL DAY SHARE CERTAINLY BEEN
A CHAMPION AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE TO A SENATOR
VALOR OF YOUR TODAY. THE
CHALLENGE WHEN HE HAS OF.
GETTING ESTIMATES OF ONE POINT
NEW HOUSE UNITS TO MEET-
PROJECTED POPULATION GROWTH HAD
ABOUT. A TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
NEW UNITS A YEAR ARE NEEDED-
NOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO ACTUALLY
CONSTRUCT. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ON LAND THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT BE USED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
THIS FORMALLY USE COMMERCIAL
RETAIL SPACE- WILL GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OF FISCAL
INCENTIVES. TO REWARD THEM FOR
REZONING- AND HELPING TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM- WE THINK IT'S A
UNIQUE PROPOSAL TO. CREATE AN
INCENTIVE TO ACTUALLY BUILD
DESPERATELY NEEDED OF
AFFORDABLE AND WORKFORCE
HOUSING AND I KNOW THERE ARE
SOME FOLKS WHO WANT TO ADVOCATE
INCLUDING A CHAT RIGHT FROM BIZ
FED ON THE LINE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR- WE WILL NOW GO TO
SUPPORTER AND THE LEAD
WITNESSES- GERARD RIGHT FROM
BIZ FED. ALSO SURVIVE MR RIGHT-
YOU WILL HAVE UP TO THREE
MINUTES I WILL KNOW TAX WE HAVE
RECEIVED NO OPPOSITION- TO
THIS- BILL SO- FEEL FREE NOT TO
TAKE THE FULL THREE MINUTES IF
YOU DON'T WANT ORTEGA YOUR
CALL. THANK YOU. NO NO PROBLEM
SENATOR WE ARE USED TO GIVE
THEM PUBLIC TESTIMONY ADVENTURE
BOARD MEETINGS WHICH IS ONLY
ONE MINUTE. FOR BROWN
ACCESSIBLE BUT A LOT OF THE
RIGHT NOW- MY NAME IS DERIVED
RATE UP ALL THE MANAGER FOR THE
LA COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION.
WE ARE A- GRASSROOTS ALIGNED TO
MORE THAN A HUNDRED NINETY
BUSINESS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
REPRESENT FORMER THOUSAND
PLAYERS. FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WE ARE WE
GIVE KUDOS TO CENTER PORTANTINO
FOR HIS. HIMSELF FOR THINKING
PROPOSAL AND WE WANT TO ALSO DO
WE PUT SOME. CONTEXT AS TO WHY
THIS IS IMPORTANT FOR US- WE
DID A HOUSING SUMMIT ARE. BACK
BACK IN LAST SUMMER AND ONE OF
THE INDICATIONS THAT WE HEARD
FROM BUILDERS AS WELL AS LOCAL
CITIES. ARE WITHIN THE BILL
SAID INSTITUTE AND MANY OTHERS-
WAS THAT LOCAL CITIES WOULD
LIKE TO BUILD MORE HAPPENING
BUT THE DRAWBACK IS THE
BASICALLY IT AT THEIR REVENUE
LOSER BECAUSE OF. ALL THE
SERVICES ARE THAT ARE NEEDED TO
BUILD INTO THE LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO- MAKE TO
SUPPORT THE HABITATION OF THESE
HOMES AND THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. WE SEE SB TWELVE
NINETY NINE IS THE RESPONSE TO
WHAT. HE CONCERNS ALONG WITH
OTHER BILLS THAT SEVEN NINETY
FIVE AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BUILD. THE HOUSING THAT THE
STATE SO DESPERATELY NEED AND
PROVIDE INCENTIVES TO GIVE
LOCAL CITIES. NOT ONLY THE
COURAGE TO DO SO BUT ALSO THE
FOUNDATION SALE IF WE DO THIS
WE'RE DOING WE'RE DOING OUR TO
DO. TO SO CORD. THE HEALTH AND
ECONOMY OF THE ENTIRE. SO WE
SEE THIS GREAT OUT. FOR THING.
HELPS WITH URBAN AND IT'LL BE.
THE PAIN ON A LOW CASE. THESE
WILL REDUCE THE NAME THE
OPPOSITION AND OTHER-
IMPEDIMENTS TO BUILDING MORE
HOUSING. AND AGAIN WE WANT TO
THANK US CENTER PORTANTINO AND
THE SENATE HOUSING HOUSING
COMMITTEE. CONSIDERATION IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH- IS THERE ANY-
SUPPORT TESTIMONY UPSTAIRS IN
THE GALLERY HERE. YES MISS CARL
A DIFFICULT FOR THE CALIFORNIA%
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT OF COMMON IN
THE GALLERY. THIRTY NINE WE
WILL GO TO TWENTY FORTY. STILL
ANTI- WHEN I GO TO THE
pTESTIMONY MODERATOR ARE THERE
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE
AGAIN THIS IS STRICTLY NAME
AFFILIATION POSITION. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THAT
TIME WE WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY
NINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SURE MEMBERS JASON RHYNE WE
CALIFORNIA CITIES WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER. I THINK
IF ANYONE ELSE IS IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THE TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION-
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION IN THE
UPSTAIRS GALLERY HERE IN. GO
TO- LONELY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
SO NOW IT'S SORT OF SAD TO SEE
THAT PICTURE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN WITH NO PEOPLE TO- KNOWN
IN TWENTY FORTY ONE I'LL GO TO
THE TELECOM IS LINE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE BEEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE OF NINETEEN. THANK YOU
AGAIN MISTER CHAIR NUMBERS
VIRGINITY GERMANS MET HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL. WE DIDN'T GET ANY LATE
LETTER OF OPPOSITION IN LAST
NIGHT- HI MY APOLOGIZE BETTER
NOT GET DEFENDER PORTANTINO
ACUITY. WE DID SUBMIT TO THE
PORTAL ON WHAT ARE OTHER
LETTERS LAST NIGHT- JUST REAL
BRIEFLY BECAUSE I KNOW I'M
PROBABLY THE ONLY ONE HERE- WE
ARE. CHANGING AND- WHICH ARE
CONCERNS AROUND EXPANDING THE
USE OF BY RIGHT. OUT
PROTECTIONS FOR WORKERS WHO-
WILL BE BUILDING THE HOUSING
THAT WILL BE CREATED UNDER USED
BY RIGHT EXPANSION.
PARTICULARLY THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS- AND WHETHER THEY ARE
ABLE TO GET THE PREVAILING
WAGE. AND WHETHER DE DEVELOPERS
NEED TO A PLACE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE ON THE
PROJECT- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
AND ITALY STATE IN THE PAST.
BUT THE WORKERS WHO ARE
BUILDING A HOUSING- ARE PAID-
AFFORDABLE ARE PAID MIDDLE
CLASS LATEST MAKING THEMSELVES.
LOOK FOR HELPING. THEY LIVE IN
WE HAVE LOOKS TO WORK WITH
PORTENT. MOVING FORWARD ON THIS
HE CAN ON OUR- AGAIN YOU
COLLEGE I FOR LATER AND NOT
GETTING WE DID IT TO THE POOR
LAST NIGHT BUT I CONCERN ARE
JUST ABOUT. EACH BY RIGHT
WITHOUT THE CAPTION
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS THAT ARE
HAVE BEEN ANOTHER BY RIGHT.
PASSED DEAN LIKE REALLY WHICH-
IN THE USE OF A OF THE TRAILER.
SO REASONS WE ARE OPPOSE TO
LESSEN THE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MODERATOR ANY ADDITION
COMMENTARIES ONLINE OR ON A
TELECONFERENCE ON. MY NUMBER
ONE TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS- MAP
BROUGHT AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS I APOLOGIZE
FOR NOT HAVING- A LETTER ON
RECORD THAT WE WOULD ACT OF THE
CONCERNS OF THE BUILDING TRADES
THANK YOU. MY NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND
ALLIED TRADES WERE LINED WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSING
NOT AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
IF THERE ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. I GET A
PROMPT- ONE AND THEN ZERO
PROPOSITION. THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN OPPOSITIONAT THE
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE HAS HIS
HAND UP. THANK YOU I MISSED
YOUR- I HAVE QUESTIONS ON THE
DEFINITION YOU KNOW THE IDEA
THAT 80% OF THE LEASE SPACE HAS
TO BE VITAL FOR A TWELVE MONTH
PERIOD THAT SAID THAT'S A
THRESHOLD THERE ARE. SEVERAL
WHAT CAN AFFECTIONATELY CALLED
BEAT UP SHOPPING CENTERS THEY
HAVE KARATE SCHOOLS IN THEM AND
METRO. AB P. METRO A TELEPHONE
SERVICES. THERE'S IT SEEMS LIKE
A VERY NARROW LIMITATION ON
SOME EXTREMELY DISTRESSED
PROPERTIES VERSUS PROPERTIES
THAT ARE GOING DOWN OR WE KNOW
WE GO DOWN I'M WONDERING IF I
HAVE TO BENEFIT THE AUTHORS-
THOUGHTS ON THAT. SHE YES
CENTER PORTANTINO SURE- WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS GO AFTER
PROPERTIES THAT. OUR I CAN
WRITE FOR THIS PROPOSAL WITHOUT
CREATING AN INCENTIVE FOR OTHER
BUSINESSES TO CLOSE SO AS FAR
AS THE DEFINITION OF WHAT
SHOULD QUALIFY I'M OPEN TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THAT WERE
JUST WE WANT TO CREATED A
DISINCENTIVE FOR. COMMERCIAL
SPACE BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY CAN COMMERCIAL SPACE
CAN GO TO HOUSING BY RIGHT TO
MEET THE DEMAND OF OUR HOUSING
NEEDS SO THAT'S THE SWEET SPOT
WE'RE TRYING TO HIT. SO WITH A
LOOK AT. HOW WE DEFINE THAT TO.
GOING FORWARD BECAUSE THAT'S
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE GOAL IS
NOT TO NOT TO CLOSE RETAIL BUT%
TO USE. CLOSED AND DISTRESS
RETAIL FOR HOUSING. I HATE.
THROUGH THE CHAIR IT SEEMS AS
THOUGH THAT THE SHOPPING CENTER
CONCEPTS. IDEA HAS COME AND
GONE- THAT'S RIGHT THANK THE
IDEA OF USING SOME OF THE
SHOPPING CENTERS THAT THAT ARE
EVEN DO WELL. ADDING HOW TO
THEM ON THE SITE IS AN
ATTRACTIVE OPPORTUNITY FOR MANY
PEOPLE WHO. HAVE AFFECTIONATELY
LOVE RETAIL AND HAVE THAT THAT
MAKES USE COMPONENT IN THERE
NOT TO DO AWAY WITH THE- WITH
THE- COMMERCIAL SHOPPING CENTER
I REALIZE THAT SOME OF THESE
AREAS ARE DEAD THERE FROM THE
OVER. YOU KNOW THE PLANNING HAS
BEEN SOMETHING TO BE DESIRED ON
THE STRIP MALL. REPLACE BUT
THERE. ARE HERE THAT I'D LIKE
TO SEE THE DEFINITIONS EXPAND
IT'S A LEASE SOME OF THESE
OTHER. FOLKS CAN BE CREATIVE
THIS IS THE ONLY POINT THAT I'D
MAKE IT RIGHT. IF I IF I GET IS
ALSO IS ON THERE ARE TWO BILLS
PENDING IN THE LEGISLATURE ONE
BY CENTER CABALLERO. ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM HAVING TO
DO WITH- REUSING COMMERCIAL
SPACE FOR RESIDENTIAL AND SO IT
SOUNDS LIKE IN- SOME WORK THAT
WILL DO IN HARMONIZING.
EVERYTHING OKAY- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS CENTER TO
ROSS SO. THANK YOU UP I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I WHEN I FIRST
HEARD THE I THAT THAT WAS
REALLY. GREAT REALLY CREATIVE
OF- AND WE ALL HAVE THEM WE
HAVE SOME SOMETHING IN OUR
DISTRICTS IN ALL. SPHERES OF- A
TOYS R. US WHAT WHATEVER IT IS
THAT'S BEEN SITTING OUT THERE
IN THESE HUGE HUGE PIECES OF
LAND- SO I THINK THAT'S A- IT'S
A GREAT IDEA BEHIND THIS BEHIND
THIS BILL I WANT TO RAISE THE
ISSUE OF- THAT IT WOULD BE
HOUSING FOR THOSE IN THE EIGHTY
TO A 120% AREA MEDIAN INCOME
LEVEL AND I KNOW SOMEWHERE
SOMEHOW- THAT'S BEEN THAT'S
WHAT DEFINES WORKFORCE ALL OF
HOUSING. I KNOW WORKING
FAMILIES THAT MAKE LESS THAN
80% THEY ARE ALSO PART OF THE
WORK FORCE AND THEY THEY
SACRIFICE A LOT AND THEY WORK
HARD FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND-
THEY NEED TO HAVE THEY NEED TO
KNOW THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM AS WELL
SO. I JUST WOULDLIKE THE I
WOULD LIKE THE AUTHOR TO THINK
MORE ABOUT HOW DO WE
INCENTIVIZE OF WORKING FAMILIES
IN THE WORK FORCE THAT ARE
BELOW THE EIGHTY PERCENT- AM
MINE THAT'S THE FIRST ONE AND
THE SECOND ONE IS- IS ALSO WHAT
I RAISED IN THE PREVIOUS.
COMPANYTHIS BILL TODAY IS
ABOUT THE LABOR STANDARDS I'M
OF IT SHOULD BE NOTED IN HERE
OFFER PREVAILING WAGE AT BUILD
AND TRAIN FOR WHICH- ARE ALL
JUST WONDERING TO THE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I WILL BE SOME
THE BILL I HAVE DO YOU WANT TO
THAT IN A CLOSE. OR NOT. GIVEN
THE- MORE LAW. THANK YOU MISS
AND THANK YOU CENTER POOR FOR
DRESS WHAT WHAT I WOULD CALL
THE SALES TAX ON ISSUE WERE
WERE ALWAYS FOCUSED ON BIG BOX
RETAILERS AS OPPOSED TO A
RESIDENTIAL BUT- I DON'T SEE
ANYWHERE IN IN MY BRIEFING WERE
THERE IS A FUNDING SOURCE. ATTY
TO PROVIDE THE TAX REBATE- WHEN
THESE PROJECTS TO REZONE SO. I
JUST WANNA KNOW WHERE THAT
MIGHT BE COMING FROM ARE WE
GIVING SOME FALSE HOPE PERHAPS
TO DISABILITIES. THE BONTA
HANDLE THAT MY CLOTHES AS WELL-
WILL HANDLE IT IS CLOSE TO
RESPOND TO. WELL YOU KNOW IF IT
REQUIRES SOME KIND OF INCOME OR
A TAX EXPENDITURE WILL GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS I BELIEVE THIS
IS KEY FISCAL SO WE WILL GO TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND WE
KNOW HOW DIFFICULT THE CHAIRMAN
OF THAT COMMITTEE IS SO THAT'S
WHY I WANT TO ASK SOME
QUESTIONS BUT ALL ALL WE- THANK
YOU MISTER. ENTER ANY AND ALL
CENTER ROTH. SEN OKAY CENTER
OFFICE WITH THE BILL CENTER
CABALLERO. I JUST WANT TO ADD
ON TO WHAT SENATOR DR SO SAID
IN- IN MY COMMUNITY I MEAN THAT
THE CHALLENGE WITH USING THE
PERCENTAGES AM I IS AT EVERY
COUNTY IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT. AND IN MY COMMUNITY.
WE MISS MOST OF THE WORKERS.
THAT WOULD BE BELOW 80% OF THE
AND MINE- SO. WELL I'M GOING TO
SUPPORT IT TODAY- FRANKLY I
THINK THIS THIS MRS FOR VETS
PRETTY MUCH ALL OVER THE
DISTRICT WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT-
IT MISS MRS MOST OF MOST OF THE
PEOPLE THAT THAT YOU THAT ONE
WOULD TYPICALLY THINK IS THAT.
IS PART OF THAT WORKS THEN IT
NEEDS TO GO A LOT A LOT. A LOT
LOWER FOR ME TO BE SUPPORTIVE
IN THE END THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. GREAT
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. THING ON SENATOR YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND- COLLEAGUES-
OBVIOUSLY WHEREVER YOU DRAW A
LINE- THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO
BE A QUESTION OF. WHY AND HOW
YOU DRAW THE LINE AND THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THE LINE. YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO. COMPLIMENTARY
SOME OF THE OTHER EFFORTS THAT
ARE GOING ON. AND OBVIOUSLY
TAKE THIS UNIQUE APPROACH AND
FOCUS ON WORKFORCE HOUSING LOW
INCOME HOUSING AND 80% STYLE
OF. OF WORKERS- YOU KNOW THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THERE SHOULD
SHOULD BE FURTHER OUR EFFORTS
TO ADDRESS THE COMPLETE PICTURE
AND HOPEFULLY THIS WILL
COMPLEMENT THE PERSONAL
CERTAINLY LOOK AT. ALL OF THE
BILLS IN. IN CONCERT AS THEY
MOVE. THROUGH THE SYSTEM TO SEE
WHERE WHERE THEY NEED TO BE
CHANGED AND ADAPTED THE SAME
GOES FOR THE LABOR ISSUES THAT
WERE RAISED SO FRANKLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN MUCH MORE HELPFUL TO
THE PROCESS HAD THEY COME
FORWARD IN THE LAST- SEVERAL
MONTHS TO HAVE SOME OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS VERSUS A SHOW UP
BUT HEY- I'M- HERE THAT THE
MORE YOU TALK THE BETTER THE OP.
ONE OF THE INTEREST SERVED WHEN
THINGS BROUGHT FORWARD. AS AS
THE PHYSICAL COMPONENT YES- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
HAS RAISED THE- AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND WE WILL BE LOOKING
AT. HOW THIS GETS FUNDED MOVING
FORWARD AND WHETHER IT FITS
INTO SOME OF THE ECONOMIC-
REDEVELOPMENT- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PACKAGES THAT ARE
MOVING TO THE LEGISLATURE AND-
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY IT'S ARE IN
AND- TO. NOT PUT SOMETHING OUT
THERE- TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT IT TO
PUTS BUT TO PUT SOMETHING OUT
THERE THAT ACTUALLY. HAD SET.
AND BILLS THE- BILLS HOUSING
AND I WOULD ASK MY COLLEAGUES
TO. MAYBE FURTHER WITH MIKE MY
OFFICE AS WEL AS HOW THE
TIMING OF THAT IMPLICATE
IMPLEMENTATION OCCURRED AND
WHAT FISCAL YEAR WE WOULD BE
SEEING THE HEAD BECAUSE OR SOME
ARGUMENTS THAT BY THE TIME YOU
DO THE ENCUMBRANCES AND THE
CERTIFICATE OF OCCUPANCY IT
WOULDN'T BE THIS FISCAL YEAR SO
WE REALLY NEED TO PLAN IT OUT A
LOT FIND IT WILL BE ADDRESSING
THOSE SEVEN. THIS AND WITH WE
ASKED FOR AND I WILL. THURMOND
MOTION HAS BEEN MADE BY CENTER
WITH THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY NINE BY SENATOR
PORTANTINO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WINNER HI WIENER AYE
MORRELL ON MORAL AYE COPYRIGHT
HI CABALLERO TIED TO RUSSELL HI
TORONTO AYE MCGUIRE. MORE LOOK
BY MRE LIKE I ROTH BY ROTH AYE
SKINNER SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
CASKEY. SEVEN SIR HOW MANY
SEVEN SEVEN VOTER TURNOUT TO
GET OUT WILL PUT HER ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR I
WILL NOW GO BACK TO ITEM NUMBER
SIX SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT- I'M
THE AUTHOR OF THAT SO I WILL IN
TURN THE DOUBLE FIGURES WE OVER
TO THE VICE CHAIR. OKAY DOKEY.
WELCOME SENATOR. AND YES
PLEASE- PRESENT YOUR BILL SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR OUR
COLLEAGUES SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT MAKES CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO HOUSING ELEMENT LAW
GUARDING A SIMPLE DETERMINATION
OF WHERE EMERGENCY SHELTERS ARE
ALLOWED AS A PERMITTED USE
WITHOUT A CONDITIONAL USE
DISCRETIONARY. ELEVEN THIRTY SO
INSURERS TIMELY ADOPTION
HOUSING ELEMENT BY REQUIRING A
JURISDICTION TO ADOPT A LEGALLY
COMPLIANT HOUSING ELEMENT.
WITHIN ONE HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS
OF THIS THREE DEADLINE WELL WE
KNOW WE HAVE A HOUSING-
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA WE DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH SHELTER IN MANY PARTS OF
THE STATE. UNDER CURRENT
CURRENT HOUSING ELEMENT LAW IT
IS A REQUIRED TO DESIGNATE
OZONE IN THEIR CITY- THAT IS BY
RIGHT FOR HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
SHELTERS BUT THE THING LONG
SEVEN LAW. WHAT WE ARE IS SOME
CITIES ARE EITHER PUT IT DOWN
IN AN INDUSTRIAL OR FAR AWAY EL
THANK. A SET IS NOT THE
SERVICES ARE FRANCE AND- THE
AREA WERE NOT. OR THEY WILL PUT
THE ZONE AN AREA THAT IS
ALREADY BUILT OUT IN A WAY
THERE IS LITERALLY NO WHERE TO
ACTUALLY PLACE TO SHELTER. SO I
STILL OWN THIRTY WILL CLARIFY
THAT WHEN YOU ESTABLISH YOUR
ZONE THAT HAS TO BE AN AREA
THAT IS NOT IN INDUSTRIAL OR
REMOTE AREA HUNTS TO BE
CONNECTED IN SOME WAY TO
SERVICES TRANSPORTATION- AND IT
HAS AN AREA WHERE THERE ARE
ACTION WAS ACTUALLY AVAILABLE
LAND- TO PLACE TO SHELTER. IN
ADDITION THERE IS- LOOPHOLES-
REGARDING THE- STARTS DOES NOT.
I TO COMPLETE YOUR ELEMENT AND
THIS IS DONE NEW POLL. US OUR
RESPECT OR ASK YOUR IBM AND
ARE IN THIS TODAY'S BRENDA GUST.
IN CALIFORNIA RURAL IS FOUND. I
WHO IS UPSTAIRS STRUGGLE. AND
YOU A- THREE MEN TO TESTIFY ON
SOME IS BUILT THANK YOU.
DRINKING CHAIR AND MEMBERS
BRIAN AUGUSTA. A PLEASE TO CO
SPONSOR THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
CAN RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND THE PUBLIC
INTEREST. LAW PROJECT- AS THE
AUTHORS DESCRIBE. THIS BILL
DOES TWO VERY IMPORTANT THINGS
TO ENSURE THAT WE GET TIMELY
ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENT. AND
THAT THE PLANNING AND THE
HOUSING OPTIONS TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WHO ARE ON HOW
IT. WILL RESULT. SITES THAT
WILL ACTUALLY DEVELOP INTO
SHELTERS. AS WE AS WE INTO THIS
NEXT ROUND OF HOUSING ELEMENTS
OF COMING IT'S GOING TO BE A
CRITICAL. TIME FOR PLANNING.
FOR THOSE NEEDS AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERY CITY IS
DOING AS MUCH AS A- THEY KIANA
TO PLAN FOR THOSE NEEDS AND
DOING SO IN A HOUSING ELEMENT
THAT IS ADOPTED IN A TIMELY
MANNER AND APPROVED. CD SO THAT
WE CAN ALL GET TO WORK HELPING
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS OF THIS
BILL HELPS TO ACHIEVE THOSE ARE
VERY PLEASED TO WORK WITH
SENATOR WIENER ON IT AND WE
WOULD URGE AND I ABOUT. VERY
GOOD ANY OTHER. WISHING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. ANY IN THE GALLERY. I YES
THEY WERE CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM TWO
OH FOR ALL WHO WISH TO TESTIFY.
NOT A NOW WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE. AND
MODERATOR FEEL PROUD PLEASE UP
PROMPTED INVENTIONS WAITING TO
TESTIFY AND I JUST WANT TO
REMIND THOSE. MOM ON THE PHONE
THE PLEASE JUST GIVE THE NAME
OF YOUR OR YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION
ON THIS BILL PLEASE. THANK YOU.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO. BUT
ONLINE NINETY FIVE. SENATOR
JEFF AMERICAN PLAINTIFFS
ASSOCIATION- WE DO HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE-
OTHER STAFF AND THE SPONSORS
AND WE APPRECIATE THEM BEING
THAT WILL CONTINUE THAT AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET TO. WORK
MAX BUT ONLINE NINETY. HELLO
THIS IS THE ROBBER NAYLOR FOR
FIELD SAID IN COMPANY IN ORDERS
COUNTY BASED BUSINESS IN
SUPPORT. AND IF THERE'S ANYONE
OUT OF SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. NO ONE ELSE CAN
MAKE YOU. NO ONE ELSE IN THE
QUEUE MODERATOR. NO ONE. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON IF THERE
ARE NO FURTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE'D LIKE TO HEAR FROM
THOSE IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
LET'S BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES
HERE IN THE GALLERY. NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO A ROOM TO-
FOR ALL ANY WE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. TO SB.
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT. OKAY THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY V.
AND- THAT TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE MODERATOR IF YOU'LL
PLEASE PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS
AND I REMIND THE- INDIVIDUALS
TO PLEASE- JUST- REMEMBER TO
GIVE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION A
POSITION ON THE. THANK YOU
MARIN OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THE TIME. AND THERE IS NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE. NO MORE IN THE
QUEUE OKAY. IF NUMBER
WITNESSES- WE NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR MEMBERS
ANY. QUESTIONS. GOING ONCE. NOT
A. SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I FIGURE RESPECTFULLY US
FROM RIVAL. MOVE THE BILL HAS
CENTER ROTH SENATOR ROCK THANK
YOU IS MOVING SB ELEVEN THIRTY
EIGHT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THIS IS SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
WINNER THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHEN. WINNER ON
A MORAL NO MORAL NO CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO TIED TO RUSSELL
TORONTO HI MCGUIRE. WARLOCK
LUCK HI ROTH BY ROTH AYE
SKINNER HI SKINNER AYE NUMBER.
WE CAL SKI. SEVEN A ONE. OKAY
SEVEN ONE DID YOU WANT TO WHO
WILL KEEP THE PUT THE BILL ON
CALL PLEASE AND I TURN IT BACK
OVER TO SENATOR. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIR I THANK
YOU COLLEAGUES ON SO WE HAVE A
HARD STOP AT TWELVE THIRTY. SO
ALL OF THE DETAILS IN A MOMENT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO AS TO FOURTEEN TEN.
TODAY UNFORTUNATELY WE THOUGHT
WE'D BE ABLE TO COMPLETE
EVERYTHING SO WE DO HAVE- AN
ADDITIONAL HEARING SCHEDULED
FOR TOMORROW BUT I THOUGHT WE
WERE COUNCIL WILL HAVE TO YOUR-
SD FORTY TEN. TOMORROW
AFTERNOON ALL WHEN WE HAD BY
GERMAN TODAY I WILL NOT GIVE
THOSE DETAILS WE ARE GOING TO
LIVE THE CALLS I'VE ALERTED.
CENTERS ON BURKE MCGUIRE ALSO
AND I. COMING. BUT TO BUT WE
ALSO PUT ON THE CAR BACK AND-
SO IT'S HANG. HANG WITH US. BUT
FOR MEMBERS WHO HAVE VOTED ON
EVERYTHING- YOU'RE GOOD. I SEE
WHEN I JUST GIVE THE DETAILS
ABOUT TOMORROW'S HEARING NOW
BEFORE EVERYONE LEAVES- SO WE
ARE GOING TO RECONVENE THIS
COMMITTEE TOMORROW- UP TIME
GERMAN OF THE BETTER VETERAN
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE IT'LL BE IN
THIS NUMBERS ARE CURRENT
LOCATION. VETERANS AFFAIRS
STARTS AT ONE THIRTY. UNA THAT
THE GERMANS. WE WILL. I'M SORRY
MIGHT. THEY HAVE ONE BILLS.
VETERANS AFFAIRS AS ONE BILL
TOMORROW ONE THIRTY SO WE WILL
PROBABLY BE DIMINISH. TO ONE
THIRTY. ONE SET BILL- VETERANS
AFFAIRS IS ONE BILL ON CONSENT
SO IT'LL BE REALLY FAST SO JUST
BE PREPARED TO- THIS WILL BE. A
COMMUTING SHORTLY AFTER ONE
THIRD ALTHOUGH THEY HAVE TO DO
SOME CLEANING I THINK SO- IT'LL
BE SHORTLY AFTER ONE THIRTY. A.
THANKS GUYS THANK YOU BYE.
NOT
ONLY GET THE I THINK ONLY ONE
OR TWO BILLS THAT HE WOULD NEED
TO VOTE ON. OKAY SO WE'RE GOING
TO START IN THE CALLS A RENEWAL
OF THE CALL ON ITEM NUMBER ONE.
SB SEVEN NINETY FIVE PER CENT
REBEL. WHO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MCGUIRE
AYE. MCGUIRE AYE I'M BURKE.
NUMBER I. EIGHT TWO TWO OKAY-
THE ROOM AS THE SEVEN NINETY
FIVE IS IT TO THE BILL IS
ADULTS ARE NEXT TO THE ITEM TO
SB EIGHT NINETY NINE BY MYSELF-
BY ME. WELL SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE MEMBERS THIS IS
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY NINE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR UMBERG. TEN ZERO.
VOTERS TEND TO ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT. NEXT ITEM THREE SB NINE OH
TWO BY ME- WELL TOGETHER PLEASE
CALL THE OFFICE NUMBER SENATE
BILL NINE OH TO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MORALE. MCGUIRE HI.
NINE ZERO. I'M SORRY YOU DIDN'T
CALL CENTER ON BURKE HE WAS NOT
HERE FOR THE- HE VOTED. RURAL
CANCERS. THERE WAS AN OF THOSE
NINE ZERO NINE ON AS THE NINETY
TWO BILLS OUT. OKAY NEXT- ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS THE- THE
CONSENT AGENDA WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR. SB TEN THIRTY. WE
HAVE SOME NUMBERS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SENATOR
MCGUIRE BY. MCGUIRE HI TEN
ZERO. HE STATE AND THE TEN
THIRTY IS OUT. NEXT ITEM FIVE
SB 1085% AND SKINNER PLEASE
CALL THE ALSO MEMBERS CYNICAL
TEN EIGHTY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR MORALE.
FIVE MCGUIRE I. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO AS TO TEN EIGHTY FIVE AS
ADULTS. ITEMS SIX SB ELEVEN
THOROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE THE
VOTE ON ONE THIRTY ENOUGH TO
ORGANIZE BECAUSE THERE IS ALSO
NO ACCOUNTS HE RETURNS.
MCGUIRE
NUMBER VOTE- AND KEEP THE WRONG
FROM HOUSE TO SO- ON GONNA LET
THE CALL ON ITEM SIX AS THE
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT BY BY YOURS
TRULY- PLEASE CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS. SENATE BILL ELEVEN
THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION ISTO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE NUMBER.
NUMBER I WOULD CAL SKI. OKAY WE
WILL TAKE THAT SORRY EIGHT
OPEN-
SEVEN BY CENTER PORTANTINO AS
BEFORE NINETY NINE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS SENATE BILL
TWELVE NINETY NINE THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE
AYE AMBER NUMBER FIVE WITH
CASCADE. NINE OUT. ROLL OVER
THE ACCOUNT SO. THE CENTERS ONE
TO STAY HERE YOUR WANT TO HANG
OUT OR YOU CAN JANUARY RIGHT
THANK YOU ARE ON.
OKAY CENTER
BECAUSE HE FOUR CORRECT- WE
WILL- NOW OPEN THE ROLE. ON
ITEM SIX SB ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT
QUOTE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
JACKSON'S MEMBER. SENATE BILL
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR CASKEY HI. WITH CASKEY
AYE. NINE ONE CAPABLE ON SB
ELEVEN THIRTY EIGHT IS NINE TO
ONE THE BILL IS OUT. AND
FINALLY WILL OPEN UP THE ROLE
ON AND SEVEN SP TWELVE NINETY
NINE. SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY
NINE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WITH
HEALTHCARE HI BUT CASKEY OUR-
CHANNEL. OKAY SPEECH FOR NINETY
NINE IS OUT. ONE SECONDS. OKAY
THANK YOU TO EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED IN AND- TODAY'S
HEARING- IF YOU WERE NOT A
TESTIFIED TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE SENATE HOUSING
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. HI AND THANKS
FOR OUR PATIENTS AND
CORPORATION- THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL RECONVENE
TOMORROW APPOINTED OF THE
VETERANS AFFAIRS COMMITTEE. AND
A HOUSING COMMITTEE WILL
CONVENE IN THIS LOCATION. THE
SENATE CHAMBERS- AND AT THIS
POINT. OUR COMMITTEE IS THE
GERMS.